hello everybody happy Friday December
2nd
we are here Dan is here uh who came back
early to keep me on the rails thank you
Dan welcome back we're joined today by
Bradley Martin the very strong
that's good the very powerful what's
that Lee Martin we're here I'm here
let's go
home
all right oh yeah yeah that was dope I
gotta say you're the first person to
match the intensity that we've been here
I've been here I appreciate that it's
that Zoo culture that's what it is yeah
so Bradley Martin of course is are you
part of nelk or are you like a satellite
nelk member or what like a I'm like a
co-host at times I'm involved in a lot
of the content I wouldn't say like I'm
specifically like a part of network in a
sense but yeah we make a lot of content
together do they pay you how does that
work
um for the content that I've done in the
past know but for the podcast stuff yeah
I'm involved there that makes sense yeah
good for you I'm happy that you you got
that spot instead of that
that [ __ ] or whoever got uh who you got
a spot so good for you do what we're
doing I'm trying yeah I love it I enjoy
it so Bradley oh just a little bit
closer yeah I got you yeah so Bradley is
here and I have I always respect when uh
I know you're a sweet guy so I wasn't I
wasn't really
um worried about you showing up here
today and breaking me in half like a
twig yeah a lot of people were saying
they're like oh he's it's like I also
I'm like I just would not do that yeah I
got a great idea I got that idea yeah
but I do respect anyone who's willing to
come in here kind of I I wouldn't call
it a lion's den because we're always
very gracious and courteous to our
guests but there's a lot a certain level
of friction I don't think yeah there's
been a certain level of friction with us
and and with your friends so yeah this
is our this is our world into the
I don't want to say manosphere it's kind
of a bad word would you consider
yourself manosphere that's not I don't
know I don't think so I kind of just
more male dominated I definitely have a
male dominant audio Yeah 100 I mean it's
like 98 wow yeah like across everything
Instagram everything
how do you feel about that 98 that's
pretty incredible that's pretty cool
I've never heard of uh percentage that
high it's all I mean I it makes sense I
think because it's just all about
workout stuff originally and then I mean
the kind of content that I made is like
you know so a little cruder as far as
humor goes and [ __ ] like that so it
makes sense that it's like girls
probably see some [ __ ] be like this is
this isn't for me this isn't for me
right yeah and it's not some of it some
of it could be workout stuff for sure
yes because girls can do the same
workouts the guys can do ladies come on
Bradley Martin's out here making content
yeah I mean that's like two percent well
I mean some I know some girls watch but
it's very very minimal wow so this is
this is good for us because I'm trying
to make peace with the men the men hate
me the yeah let's just be real we have
the women though yeah with the women I
noticed that I noticed I just said
Twitter so let's bring I want to bring
the people together yeah and so what
we've done this before what I want to do
is bring out the vice and the beef we're
gonna squash the beef here today okay
uh metaphorically and literally so is
there is that the beef under this yeah
is it cooked beef oh it's liver king
beef okay all right
wow this is interesting
you guys got sound bites and everything
yeah oh yeah and Jackson mad uh wizard
back there he's our soundbite guy yeah
so and by the way liver King sat right
here and yelled subprime at me because I
couldn't eat I put it in my mouth but I
couldn't down the raw Bowl testicles and
I'm like bro yeah what's up problem it
was really not good I had it on my pod
as well it was just not not something
I'd recommend except the one thing I did
like was the barrel
open it I did like the marrow the
Merrell was good I agree the Merrell was
good the mirror was good it was all bad
from there yeah the testicle just the
texture was not it just tasted like
Rusty
[ __ ] wow but you like you like the
inspiring music yeah no it's honesty
this is sweet do you eat raw meat I have
I don't do it consistently good for you
yeah yeah
I'm proud of you
should be working together teamwork yeah
team building so am I just gonna just
squish this no no not yet not yet not
yet just just hold it in place okay okay
perfect thank you do I need to wash it
uh yeah probably by the way I want to
say this setup is incredible I'm
actually pretty envious of this thing
you guys have a good thing going solid
team we do have the greatest team yeah
we do they're the best in Biz I'll be
right back
foreign
do the sound bites are great I hope I
get sound bites out of this I need to
make some like crazy sounds do we have
any Zach we gotta have sound bite yeah
play some sound bites of me
none of Brad but uh person uh that
you're familiar with yeah we do have a
lot
oh I can play you some of your friends
yeah but yeah yeah yeah
like no no shoddies or anything
don't be shy don't be shy
does it play that one again
yeah Donny you go cow style cow style of
Donny
uh yeah dog this is good Ripa Dart is a
favorite I'm just spitting facts you
know
I'm gonna go rip a dart yeah
so um
here's the beef yeah we've got it in the
vice I'm ready to squash it so okay is
first of all is there anything you want
to talk to me about yeah anybody yeah go
ahead please sorry I wasn't waiting for
this moment yeah and I don't want to say
this one of preface this by saying I
prior to like these exchanges or
whatever I didn't have much to go off of
like content that you made I knew you
made in concert for a long time and I
can't say Obviously like you don't have
a big fan base because I know that you
do I was only going to say that my issue
was the things that were said about me
in relationship to this thing as a whole
because
basically my two interactions that I
ever had with you or knowing of you were
two negative interactions so the first
time I found out about you I don't know
if I could say this guy's name or not
because I know you could have beef with
them in the past but team star yeah so I
knew about them so I knew about the
negativeness with keemstar and then I
didn't look into it much but that's how
I found out about you for some reason I
knew about him that I found out about
you through that okay right and then the
second time that I was exposed to you
was the the video that you were saying
like oh he's keeping his gym open for
this reason yeah so both times we're
both negative times so that my my
original reaction to you was like the
only the only stuff that I'm
understanding from him is negativity
right or like a Viewpoint of Me Without
Really knowing me right and then making
an assessment on me without fully
understanding me or why I might make
decisions right and then I want to also
say this you're the only person that
I've ever had any sort of like now I
guess beef with right which is not
really necessarily real beef where I've
actually had someone in person come up
to me where we were driving we were
walking down the street kawanga
Boulevard Hollywood like a few nights
ago and some girl Drives By and girl
you're talking about the girl on
Instagram earlier literally a girl was
like uh what did she say about Steve she
was like
yeah Steven Brown she was like I swear
to God I swear to God and I was like so
my three interactions so I just want to
say your audience is you know you know
what I was about to reprimand them but
that's kind of funny it was no honestly
was funny she drove by and Lily was like
she said it and then did the I was like
oh my God and that's never happened to
me like for the record for the record
yeah this man has never jerked off a dog
no no
he's a happy dog
regardless right that dog is set um the
dog's doing good yeah Donnie is a he's
he's doing good so that was my only
thing I was like I felt like you had
this assessment based on like well I
always keep my gym open I was like yo
it's like it's not that simple because
it's a lot deeper than that well the
reasons why yeah and I can understand
why at the time people would you know
have you know emotional reactions to why
and I just have my own reasons for why
it was important for me and what I knew
it meant to me when I was young growing
up and what I knew him into a lot of
people as well yeah so okay that's it
that's all I really so that's fair I
mean I'll be honest you know I I can be
abrasive I can be I am by my own
definition a hater ass [ __ ]
I'll just say that okay that's fine it
came out this year as a South Brooklyn
hitter as a [ __ ] yeah
yeah learning about yourself and like
yeah because so here's here's my thing
and I'll take it one more step further I
was thinking like because if you make
content like that in my mind I'm
thinking I'm looking at all the content
I made over the years not all most
positive beneficial content every aspect
but I never made content that was just
like picking apart someone else's
content reviews you know yeah like so
that's why I felt attack and I was like
what the [ __ ] like I've never I never
said [ __ ] this guy because he likes this
or he's like that or he believes this
that's why I was like you know yeah I
get that I get that especially because
you're not you don't do controversial
stuff you don't cause problems for
anyone and by all accounts and I can
tell sitting from here today uh you are
a very nice guy and you and uh you know
when when Steve started talking about
how like uh yeah that's when he was ugly
and I'm fat and by the way we're not we
don't take offense but you stood up for
us yeah Bradley Martin the Saint
Saint Bradley Martin he stood up press
he said don't dog the man's wife and we
yeah I know there's a nice guy I
immediately appreciated that oh thank
you and like even though you know
whatever A lot of people say that so
like Ethan said it's not new to us but
it was nice to see your immediate
reaction was like well don't go there
like why yeah I mean something some
things are just not always necessary but
we're not offended there's no beef about
or anything I just thought it was nice
to see someone actually like don't do
that instead of like yeah he's fat and
she's ugly which is like kind of what
we're used to well it's silly though
yeah well if you're the man what can I
say and so um I understand your reaction
100 get it
you know and I'm coming out to you a
little bit just gonna open up and get a
little bit of emotional here like I said
like earlier this year I came out as a
hater ass [ __ ] damn it's big and and
you know I I have a problem I tend to um
come out very hot and very heavy yeah
and while it is entertaining it does
cause a lot of problems for us
yeah both getting we got two strikes
this year yeah I saw that yeah that's a
lot of beefs a lot of beef some squashed
we had some great squashing of beefs too
age-old rivalries age-old robberies yeah
squashed and I'm here happy to do it
today with you yeah we got banned twice
once for uh
oh I said something like I was gonna you
know so much you know I'm not gonna say
it but like like do you you know yeah I
knew about the
uh the me award yeah use the acronyms if
you can yeah I'm like how do I say this
there was the NRA one and the Ben
Shapiro one yeah so well I knew about
the Ben one I didn't know about the
other one and Ben Shapiro the other one
was very similar and I'll say to Ben
Shapiro since he is watching he should
be the first to join me for Hanukkah
dinner with me okay because I am Jewish
and I think we could have a lovely time
together
even though I do think he's a demon what
do you think about all this Kanye stuff
can I ask about that oh yeah of course
oh it's scary I'm like shocked yeah
I mean like yesterday I was telling
Ethan like I just like like what is
actually happening with this guy is this
really what he always was like because
for a while people were like well he's
mental problems and whatever it's having
episodes and there were all kinds of
excuses and you kind of like are like
okay maybe like we shouldn't judge too
much but it's more and more is coming
out that like this is just like insanity
I don't know what to make of it anymore
yeah we were talking about it back here
and it's like
it's like it's almost like he's
engineered for himself the most
thorough way to destroy his life like
he's walking around with Nick Fuentes
who is like
like math and Magic mathematically
created like the biggest piece of [ __ ]
toxic person you can cruise around with
and he's flying with him everywhere and
he's going on just straight like I love
love Hitler like the man is on a
speedrun to ruin everything and I think
and I don't mean and I don't want this
to happen I think it's sad what's
happening with this man is that we think
he's trying to speedrun his death oh
really really I mean I don't know
anything about and I don't know if he's
gonna be dead within two years for sure
and I don't want that I haven't thought
about that but I think that's what he
wants I don't know I again I don't know
anything about this Nick fuent this guy
at all but I also I also don't know
um I don't know I feel like he's
Connie's also the person that like it
seems like even if he lost everything he
could still make it back somehow he
really it really feels like that to me
I'm not to a level yeah to an extent I
think dude like Beyond before all this
latest development it always felt that
way but it's like he's pushing it like
as far as it could be and I don't know
that it could be a reverse do you guys
see the thing is the the idea of Love
Speech and the idea like he's trying to
show love equally to everyone that's
kind of like what he's talking about
it's a form of like yeah being almost
jesus-like yeah and I think that the the
the issue with it becomes when
you you say something with a massive
platform and people who might hear it
they only see like a bit of it because
people are just seeing that clip running
on Tick Tock of him being like I love
you know what I'm saying you clip that
you don't watch the whole thing oh no
the whole thing is just as bad it's
worse it's worse yeah he says it like 12
times it's not it wasn't taken out of
context
like he was like he emphasized he wanted
people to know I love the Nazis I love
Hitler and Alex Jones kept trying to
save him trying to get him to back off
he's like no you like the way they dress
right because they're fashionable Alex
Jones yeah Alex Jones was like
distancing himself from yeah oh [ __ ] and
he's like I don't believe that just for
the record you know I I I don't believe
what what you just said and he's like so
you like the way they dress right you're
just saying that he's like no I love
you talk about this like you talk about
speed running like to his death you're
talking about like a suicide or
something like that suicide or
assassination Ian brought up a good
point or an interesting point is that
Ian maybe you could you could tell
better than me
I was just saying he he recently he was
spotted walking around Los Angeles with
no security
um he was in an interview and the guy
was like why do you not have security
and he was kind of like what happens to
me happens to me
it sounds like he's just not using
security whatsoever anymore uh which is
interesting he's inviting
I don't know man I I hope not I mean
it's sad it's really scary though to see
like that level of just like open
anti-Semitism and just straight like
yeah I'm a Nazi it's cool I feel like it
keeps trying to like be like nobody can
put a label on me like I can say that I
like Nazis like we should be able to say
anything yes but it's like how much like
say anything like to what point why why
do you need to like go as far as like
starting to put the Holocaust in
question like I just don't know it's
just insane the other thing he did on
Alex Jones he goes six million Jews
definitely didn't die in the Holocaust
like everybody knows that so it's like
he's playing with Holocaust denialism
and [ __ ] like you know what I mean like
he's going all M yeah so I guess you
can't come back from that I don't think
so because that's
Hitler
that's [ __ ] yeah and then [ __ ] yeah
it's it's I haven't watched it I just
saw clips and I'm like maybe there's and
I saw some other Clips like in points
and like maybe look kind of good but
maybe it's overall it's not yeah I mean
you should watch it it's fascinating
watch how long is it uh he was on there
for like I don't know an hour or two of
just yeah yeah
but anyway let's let's do this so we
don't have to stare at the Robbie all
the time
so um regarding you know I learned a
little bit about it I love doing the
music yeah did you start that no that's
Jack oh nice you guys are on it
okay because this is a beautiful moment
and I want it to be felt as like
so um
you know I learned a little about your
background and why the gym is important
to you so important too and I it makes
it really does inform uh a lot about how
I feel about you and it gives me a a lot
of respect for your experience and what
you've been through yeah I don't know if
you want to openly talk about like uh
maybe or I I know I read online about
your your father yeah yeah are you
comfortable talking about that yeah yes
so Bradley's father uh committed suicide
uh when you were young right how old is
six six yeah and that I I can imagine
just how dead I mean I can't imagine but
I understand that that that's
devastating and so you turned to the gym
in that moment and it and it was a type
of therapy for you is that right yeah I
mean essentially like my whole life
growing up I looked for father figures
and my coaches I played Sports I played
football and then when I found the gym
specifically it that whole environment
felt like you have that kind of like
male reinforcement because typically
when you're working on those those kind
of environments for me I'm younger I'd
say around like 16 17 years old there
was always like an older group of men
that would be like do this or try that
and like that experience and that kind
of like camaraderie was something I
always search for so then I really found
it and I can find it every day and I was
like finding myself spending a lot of
time in the gym not even just training
just being there to like speak to
basically these older men that I looked
up to essentially because I didn't have
that my whole life so I was like kind of
looking for
um that sort of attention that sort of
love that sort of guidance yeah yeah so
yeah do you do you have memories are you
you said you were six when he uh passed
yeah so you have a lot of memories with
him and stuff or oh how was that no I
have one one like most vibrant memory oh
it's gonna make me cry [ __ ]
take your time it's all right yeah
you know I became a father recently so
there's a perspective of me that just
what a special relationship that is I
understand it from the the father role
um yeah so the one memory that I have uh
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] because I remember the
like the sign of conversation in it
um it was oh [ __ ] we were uh
and this is pretty much the only one
next to a memory where like I remember
myself kind of walking up because my
parents had split when I was five and
then he went and lived in a different
house and we'd go I'd go visit him
basically during that like time before
it kind of like you know he went away
basically
um I remember like coming up to the
house I remember those moments but I
don't really have very many like Vivid
memories with him except this moment
where it was Easter and I was spending
time with him we were coloring eggs
and uh
basically talking to him like that
[ __ ]
uh that it's I said to him I remember
saying to him are we gonna do this every
year and then obviously not right
uh yeah and I just remember him saying
yeah we'll do it every year I remember
that memory damn that's like pretty much
the only one
probably a sense of like uh
a deep sense of Abandonment at that
point right yeah I mean not obviously
not right away but I I remember
growing and just you know you're in high
school you're friends you see your
friends with their dads and you're like
yeah like I want that and I would try to
spend time around those people to have
that or I'd spend time around sometimes
the wrong people to have like older like
cousins or people that were in other
people's lives and I looked at them as
like uh you know someone who's
somewhat of a father figure and find
myself kind of like not the best
positions but
I was always just kind of looking for
that and that's why when I like I told
you when I found the gym it was like
damn this is this is what I've always
wanted what I've always been looking for
so yeah I respect that and you know the
gym is a it's a good Outlet too it's
healthy you know what I mean like I saw
you recently you were on a live and you
were uh you're running oh you saw that I
saw that because about 30 pounds dude
yeah I'm proud of you that's amazing for
real yeah yeah good [ __ ] I'm going I'm
still going I got a lot a long time ago
because everyone told me that you said
the gym was like a waste of time yeah
that's all that's kind of like the funny
Tick Tock meme yeah of it and it just
it's so funny because I I think working
out is great I support working out I
have a ton of respect for people that go
to the gym and do put in the work
because what the gym is one of the only
things in life it doesn't matter your
status it doesn't matter how rich you
are it doesn't matter how much privilege
you have or lack of everyone has to put
in the same amount of effort right yeah
uh there's no there's no shortcuts yeah
I also I also think I want to add on to
I also think the Gym's such a great
place because it's a physical
representation of like everything
involving success in your life right
like in order for you to get good at
something like even we talked about I
came here I was like this is amazing
amazing you started somewhere small yeah
right you got bigger because you knew
that oh we needed to grow we needed to
get bigger I'm not saying physically
grow but you talk about a guy in the gym
he wants to get bigger he has to put
himself through that stress to get
bigger he has to tear the muscle down to
build it up right so you have to go
through the painful part of it and it's
just it's cool to me because it's a very
physical representation of oh I think
all success but you have to go through
the growing pains you have to make
mistakes you have to learn from all the
things to get better to where you want
to be that's why I love the gym so much
so I want to I want to emphasize I do I
have mad respect for people that like
maintain these incredible bodies through
just share you know willpower
but what I said about the gym it was
literally just one silly joke I made
about how I was doing math in my head I
said if you're on a treadmill
an hour every day yeah
and someone like me I probably exercise
to prolong my life to be healthy right
yeah like some people exercise to get
muscle and look good or whatever what I
don't know the your reasons uh but but I
assume it's something like that yeah I
mean it's it's evolved over time like
it's been like originally I started
because like I said I just love being in
that atmosphere so much and then I
remember at one point uh I was at a gym
and I was a trainer and someone's like
you should you should do this
competition stuff this men's physique
things coming out it was a brand new
class of like the NPC which wasn't
bodybuilding but like you could wear
shorts on stage and like but like look
just like you got abs and good shoulders
right she was like you'd be good at this
so I did it and then it evolved into
like the internet and all this stuff and
because it wasn't a thing when I wasn't
like I'm gonna work out to be on the
internet because like my timing was like
I got on Instagram in like 2010 2011
before it was like this thing that it is
now that people do it because they think
I'm gonna become some like Fitness
influencer right I just did it because
someone was like you should try and then
I was like yeah [ __ ] it and then I just
enjoyed the process of like continuing
and growing yeah better yeah okay
so anyway I did this mental experiment
that I thought was funny so let's say
you work out an hour every day yeah and
so that's you know uh uh seven hours a
week it was 52 weeks in a year maybe
you'll enjoy this joke give me the
crunching a sound Zach so we got 52 okay
weeks in a year all right right times
seven hours a week okay that's 364 hours
per year on the treadmill yeah okay and
then I can expect to live let's say
let's be let's be real here when you
think I'm dying
this is like actually a really it's a
good question because yeah because
honestly like you but that's the thing
you could change yeah yeah with your
actions so that's why it's like the
cardio specifically decreases like your
ability on your ability your all-cause
mortality by like a ton like your your
ability to stay alive longer is much
higher so like video is so hard it is I
I don't even do anything straight up
yeah because I just want to lose the fat
and I figure that's the best way to do
it just cardio you know yeah kind of
yeah you definitely want to step into a
master here yeah you kind of want to
balance because like you also got to
understand like not necessarily that you
need a bunch of muscle but having more
muscle does make it also easier for you
to eat more [ __ ] when you eat more [ __ ]
or burn more calories at rest so it I
like you did [ __ ] not actually though no
not [ __ ] not [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll eat anything
bro
really no I'm talking about actually
[ __ ] no I'll eat it [ __ ] it damn okay
maybe with some salt on there some salt
Bay yeah no but but what I'm saying is
like I
if I ate liver King [ __ ] I'd probably
have enough steroids to last me a year
oh my God that's kind of an interesting
experiment
s
[ __ ] dude no but I don't I can't give
you exact date I mean I wouldn't know
man you could change his 80 generous 80
. I'm not making it to 80. [ __ ] yeah
yeah so maybe seven let's say 75.
yeah that's fair
what you don't think I'll make it past
six yeah there's like unknowns too
before let's just say in my current you
take a bet at 64. yeah bro really sorry
dude okay let's Okay Bradley because
look remember you're talking about how
many cardio you're doing and you're
talking about hours how long do you sit
if you have you ever done the time
you've ever crunched the time for that I
don't want to know that exactly
for a bad purpose obviously you know you
know your parents are having fun but
like that is also just not the most
optimal well now I'm doing a car uh an
hour a day on the treadmill that's
pretty good that's amazing yeah she's
been doing it every day difficult I'm
not doing that thanks bro thank you so
much I do want to say I've been
exercising twice a week you do I do oh
yeah let's go let's go I'm surprised I
got really strong I love it do you feel
better I do at first I hated it so much
it was so hard normal um like yeah you
just feel like [ __ ] and like you can't
do anything and if you feel like you're
worthless so how long have you been
doing it now maybe two months oh you're
good then you know the first month's the
hardest thing you hate that habit
because like just it's just people just
eventually go like two three weeks and
like [ __ ] this and then you stop and
then you have to try again but if you
could actually make it a habit then
you're [ __ ] golden I started because
of back pain and it really went away
like it's crazy I had the worst back
pain because I you know we have two
babies yeah so the second pregnancy
really just like killed my back
um so I was like I have to do something
because this back pain is killing me
yeah and I saw a doctor and he was like
this is just muscles you just gotta work
on your muscles you just need to
strengthen it right yeah so here is
cures so much [ __ ] man yeah and balances
all that so uh well my problem with it I
I [ __ ] I'll just be real and don't
take this personal because that's fine
no yeah I [ __ ] hate exercising though
it's fair dude a lot of people hate it I
hate it and I tried I got a personal
trainer I even went for like two months
straight oh you went too much yeah it
still stopped that I [ __ ] hate it you
know what was so weird before he stopped
he was doing it twice a week for two
months and then he was like I'm gonna
start every day and he started talking
to his trainer about like the schedule
and by doing it every day and then he
quit yeah then I went off the rails yeah
you explained that yes you got to find
more balance then because like so
especially if you hate it right away and
you hate it so much like it can't be an
everyday thing because you're just gonna
get overwhelmed with it so the thing is
I'm happy now is that I found something
that I like and works for me and I don't
like uh dread doing it which is the
treadmill because I can watch TV I can
like zone out on other [ __ ] yeah and so
that's been working for me and so I've
been working out really consistently but
back to this mental yeah experiment so
you think I'm gonna die at 64. okay Brad
that's [ __ ] up sorry no be realized
yeah no I'm being honest yeah I better
start I'm going to be pissed
at 64. I'm not trying to die at 64. yeah
we got to change that I'm working on it
okay so
so okay now we said
364 hours a year okay so now we're going
to time that by 64. now I know I haven't
been exercising my whole life but let's
just pretend like I have that's 23
000
296 hours
exercising okay now let's take those
hours
okay and divide it by 24.
okay that is not
970 days exercising
and where are we going hold on hold on
there's a point there's a point okay
okay this is a this is a uh this is the
joke that got me in trouble with all of
tick tock okay 970 days divided by 365.
we're looking at 2.65 years straight on
the treadmill so I said to myself this
exercising thing is it it's just a giant
scam because if I just spent that time
on the treadmill doing something else
maybe maybe the time I spent on the
treadmill will end up being less than
the life I save doing not not doing it
yeah I see what you're trying to say and
boy I ended it by saying the numbers
don't add up okay so here's the thing
you should not take into account then
right you're not taking into account the
way you might actually feel so the
quality of your life can be completely
different so not just you like losing
the weight right and like you're gonna
like feel better overall like entirely
like sexually mentally everything is
better so it's like wouldn't you also
want the quality of your life while
you're here to be better just that
because you're not spending less time
like at the gym so that's true but also
the numbers don't even come close to
adding up because I'm dying at 64 right
so let's say I get down to a healthy
weight yeah then what then what are we
feeling
you I mean that number could you can go
for tremendously yeah you might live
forever yeah forever knurling [ __ ]
Elon Musk [ __ ] yeah I'll be in The
Matrix in no time so that could be 80
easily so that's that's 16 years plus
and so I'm spending 2.6 years on the
treadmill and I'm saving 16 plus years
so to me that's a good deal and I crunch
the numbers yeah and I said the numbers
don't add up it's a good deal but on
Tick Tock all the but it was a stupid
joke that meant nothing to all of us
here it was just like Ethan being silly
yeah that's all that it was but it is
community serious dude
it became like what everybody references
about dude and so what's now he's that
guy that said that that's it yeah I
remember I heard that too of course it's
like I became like a meme in the gym
fitness world and they all hate my guts
they go and it turned into all these
crazy things like Ethan thinks that
exercising's for Betas Ethan thinks
people The Exodus are Freaks and then
girls because we have a predominantly
women fan base they sending DMS of guys
that they're dating or talking on Tinder
like what do you think about H3 they're
like I [ __ ] hate them yeah
yeah but here like this is the kind of
deal that dropping like this one 220 223
000 likes and by the way this anime in
the front
this is exercise I'm just gonna be
honest there's so many better things to
do than exercise it is a Shame by the
way I [ __ ] with the Showbox
then they gotta hit me with the Socrates
quote they hit you with a real quote too
that I've seen
too much
yep I knew that he hit you bro let's go
waistline yeah damn but it's also too
like you gotta think to the gym and like
these activities like obviously you just
sit on a treadmill was very like
singular yeah a lot of these like I said
earlier the camaraderie in the gym like
you even if you spend time if you're
spending time there with like your
friends it's also not just working out
right it's a sort of a social
environment as well even if you did
social yes my social damn that's okay
that keeps me in the basement but even
if like you guys went like worked out
together like you know maybe went on a
little easy jog whatever like you could
do that and it's not it's not just time
spent doing that right yeah it's also
bonding I feel you there's more than
that yeah there was a time when actually
in high school I was really fit I played
water polo I mean he played water polo
was that cough like a fig you didn't
actually play waterboard it's a gurg no
no that's real I play waterfall no no no
no I played waterfall yeah really I was
super you play water polo yes dude I
need to see a picture of you is there a
picture of someone probably yeah that'd
be amazing
my whole life I went to college and what
happened
what happened was that because it
doesn't just happen to be honest with
you what happened was probably that
um well I gained a tremendous amount of
weight in the past two years when I
started uh antidepressants yeah and so
that's a side effect and I gained like
80 pounds from doing the medicine and so
that that was one of the big drivers
because I was never like super fat until
I started that and before that take that
yeah why do you take it
uh it helps me really I like it I love I
like it I love it the only downside of
it was that
it made me fat as [ __ ] and so but I
found a way now to stay on the medicine
because I like what it does for me and
to still to be able to lose the weight
have you ever considered not taking the
medicine
um so I started the medicine like two
years ago and I my life was like a
[ __ ] train wreck before it like
mentally or well I was more than two
years like four years probably more than
two years that's why I took away before
Theodore was born right did you start
gaining weight before you took the
medicine at all I was slowly gaining
weight but I was going through like ups
and downs though like he was able to say
like I'm gonna go on a diet and then
like you really see results I guess my I
guess my only thought to this like
antidepressant thing because I think
like overall like it's not the best
thing to be stuck on your whole life
right because obviously there's problems
that come with it yeah but it's also
like I don't know I really do believe
diet the things that you eat in your
activity can change your need for those
things and it's like maybe if you never
gave that a real shot then you wouldn't
really know like hey you understand
like if you ever gave that a real shot
like I did I have I have yeah you did I
have died it was way beyond that okay I
don't know obviously yeah I was I was
um
I was a wreck man yeah I was gonna quit
YouTube I was gonna quit everything our
marriage we were having trouble
everything was miserable and what was
causing it
I think it was the stress of the job
just making content yeah before we made
the podcast I had like this YouTube
channel that I would make a video for
every week and it just became so hard
and I felt like there was crazy
expectations and one of when I really
started gaining weight when I went to
college I developed like an anxiety
disorder and that really [ __ ] me up
for a long time too so it's all related
and I started gaining weight from that
and um
but there was a time also when I lost
like 50 pounds before you came so even
before the antidepressants yeah yeah
yeah way before and so I I had control
over I felt like I had control like I
could I could lose 10 pounds but once I
started that I lost control yeah it's
weird but now I feel like I've uh
figured something out that works for me
but I don't I don't I don't share the
same opinion about antidepressants and
stuff I think they're actually I think
you know it's funny because when I was
younger I had the opinion like oh
everyone's over prescribed medicine and
the you know there's other ways to do it
but I still got older and started using
it myself I understand that um
there's really there's actually nothing
wrong with taking it and I I feel like
maybe it's too stigmatized at this point
where people see themselves as weak or
something if they if they take a
medicine like that because in my opinion
fat being the only downside and
obviously that's a big downside but I'm
working on it but the benefits of it for
me it turned my whole life around dude
like it was it was relevatory I mean it
really saved me because I always just
I'm always just curious like could there
have been other things that could have
happened instead of that that would have
also changed your life and turned it
around yeah I feel like I had tried a
long time okay I wasn't sure it was like
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna do this he waited
on taking it for like maybe two years
okay it was like in my bedside right
yeah and I was very much like I don't
want to do it I'm scared of what's going
to do to me I'm stronger than this I can
deal with this because the doctor gave
it to me and I was like I'm not ready to
take it so I was trying everything I
could and then when I did started taking
it and I saw how much it helped me
um I felt like an idiot for not taking
it soon what I guess propriet to being
like okay I need to take this what
bothered you the most that you felt like
you needed to
like change or feel oh my mood I was
just super irritable
super moot like crazy mood swings
um the irritable it just sounds but it
sounds like your hormones were [ __ ] up
did you ever get like your blood work
everything's fine I did blood work that
was perfect yeah damn yeah that's fine
even before getting on the stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah no my my I got blood a
bunch normal yeah and they did a full
blood panel yeah everything was fine and
I did that like a few times within over
like a 10-year span because I kept going
back and trying to figure out what was
going on it's always fine like he's got
no medical issues too no back pain
no nothing I'm always like what is going
on no back pain let's go oh yeah now I'm
going to [ __ ] develop some [ __ ] up
like rare form of cancer since you said
that yeah oh well that's good at least
at least you checked and you're you're
made sure I wasn't just like I'm just
gonna do this no I didn't want to take
it I guess I put it off we thought also
we had all these fears like because of
what we do is creative like is it going
to mess up with our work or yeah I don't
know we had all these like fears about
it but like it actually did the opposite
dude because because you feel so much
more like calm I guess yeah as a
creative function you're more functional
as a creative person that was my biggest
fear is like how What's it gonna do like
for my functions and when I started
taking it I found it I had like a
Renaissance afterwards because I wasn't
in my head all the time anxiety disorder
I have like a generalized anxiety
disorder and it was really bad it comes
and goes now I've been on top of it for
a long time uh but it might actually
relate to that yeah it can be
debilitating yeah and so this really
helped with that and it honest I frankly
had like a personal Renaissance from
this creatively with work and um the
podcast that you see today I was doing
it once a week and I hated coming to the
office I hated the product I was just
everything was so negative once I
started that I like started like coming
in I started like spending time with the
guys I said hey one's not enough let's
start and now we're doing five episodes
a week every weekday live like
everything that we do yeah everything
that we're doing now seemed impossible
back then like getting along with the
crew even yeah or being able to like
maintain relationships uh have a
positive work environment yeah do a
podcast and be happy with it afterwards
like we would do once a week and hate it
afterwards like this was [ __ ] I just
hate it I totally get it and and that's
amazing because this is incredible what
you guys are doing like the amount of
shows and like the amount of content
output I just think it's important I
guess we're talking about the subject
that I I do people listening because I
don't want someone to hear this and be
like I'm just going to get an
antidepressants because it made Ethan's
life better because my life's messed up
or something I I do want to say that I
think it is important that anyone
listening like you did you gave it time
you thought about it you got your blood
work done you didn't just say that's the
one thing I need and you went for that
you know what I'm saying I don't think
people do that I think most people are
not hesitant I think most people are
like I don't want to take this I'm
afraid to take it most of the time when
I hear people they say I was putting it
off I was afraid I was nervous to take
it
and now I that I tried it I'm super
happy that I did that's exactly how I
felt about Ayahuasca
Ayahuasca you can't take that because of
the antidepressant yeah you're right I
can't do any fun drugs that's one of the
shittiest Parts about it yeah I can't do
any fun drugs man I just did Ayahuasca
you just did it amazing how long ago
about a week ago two weeks ago yeah no
he didn't do it oh no he's afraid were
you by yourself I was with the uh Shaman
is typed up are you doing yeah just you
and the shaman yeah huh tell me about it
so where did you do it about it the
house my house so the shaman came to
your house how'd you find the shaman uh
a friend of mine it's a it's a are they
Shaman are they like a white lady named
no no no no no no no this guy doesn't
speak any English he's from Colombia oh
hell yeah so he's like like he did this
like his it's like in his family like
they grew up doing this okay okay so it
wasn't like just some random he lives in
L.A no he lives in he flew in for this
flew in from Columbia whoa so you paid
for him to fly in some premium yeah
experience yeah so that this is this so
this is an expensive Journey yeah it
wasn't she huh yeah but it sounds like
it was working but I wanted to do it the
right way I wasn't like I just want to
take this thing right because there's
like there's there's been used for like
thousands and thousands of years like
you gotta have some sort of reverence
for it instead of just showing up being
like I'm taking drugs yeah yeah because
I was doing it with a purpose so you
float so you contact this guy your
friend had used him before yeah five
stars multiple times yeah yeah yeah
highly highly reviewed yeah so you fly
him out not someone from Venice being
like yo bro drink this stuff yeah yeah
yeah so how long did it take the plan
from the time you contact him until he
comes out it was quick it was like uh it
was well so let me make this clear I I
didn't I had been thinking about doing
this for like the last two years and
just like you were talking about I was
afraid of it I was so afraid of doing it
but I knew that there was like there
could be so much benefit from it so for
like the last six months I was
contemplating it and then but from the
time that I said yo I want to do this to
like it happening it took like about
maybe two weeks a week okay for him to
like set up come out interesting well
watch him to you like you could gain
from The Experience like what is it so
like similar to you I deal with a lot of
anxiety I deal with a lot of like uh
caught up in thoughts around like the
idea of death and my my own sense of
worth and being good enough and like
doing enough in this life and in my in
that being related to also my fear of
death like because I feel like I was
never enough
um kind of has to go go back to like my
father and the fact that my father took
his life and I obsessed about the idea
of death for so long since I was a kid
because I you know when you're six you
everything prior to like a very serious
moment is just kind of like oh I'm with
my friends I fell totally it's all
everything's temporary and then
realizing your dad's gone and my mom
told me that I'm like what does that
even mean that's a big so since I was a
kid I've obsessed with the idea of death
like what what's my life supposed to be
like what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do here what is life what is
death what is all this and I thought
about that since I was really young so
I've always had like general anxiety but
also anxiety around just the idea of my
own mortality
um so I wanted to figure out a way to
kind of like heal my my trauma in the
sense like in relation to
the the kind of the assumptions I made
around my father taking his life and it
not being related to me because
obviously I know in hindsight now being
33 looking back a six-year-old made this
like assumptions with like oh I'm not
good enough for my father to stay right
because that's the only thing that can
happen so sad it's [ __ ] and but then I
now I'm 33 I have this Hinds how I'm
able to look back and say okay well
obviously all these things in life
experience that I've now gone through I
could realize that it's not as simple as
what a six-year-old thought yeah you
know because I now have the the know of
my life and all the things that I've
gone through not saying it's okay for
someone to take their life but there's
more understanding of why it may or may
not have happened right so I was trying
to I'm trying to get uh more clear just
Vision in my life and just being able to
Like Love More
freely without holding and like being
afraid of doing it and holding back and
because of my trust in the idea that if
I do then someone's going to leave me or
I'm going to feel left again I'm going
to feel like I wasn't good enough and
that person's gone you know so that I
had struggle with that with all my
relationships in my life and for me it's
like I got to a point where I'm like I'm
33. I wanna you know I want a beautiful
wife I want to have a family I want to
have that and it's like I can't have
that if I'm so afraid of allowing myself
to have it so the idea was I'm gonna do
this it's a part of obviously it doesn't
just fix something but the idea is like
to
get me closer to the feeling of it
because
have you ever taken psychedelics yeah
yeah a lot yeah amazing so you know yeah
I love that I love that so like uh yeah
yeah I [ __ ] around with it so
psychedelics for me is just I I've
always felt in those moments just more
connected to myself obviously without
the ego in the sense of how I should be
or how people should view me or how I
should it's like just who I am and the
Ayahuasca and the one that I took a
Yahoo specifically is like the strongest
version of this and it just like doesn't
allow you to see anything else but like
yourself like and you're like confronted
with it it just feels like it's very
unavoidable and you have to kind of go
through it
you can't just be like Oh I'm going to
think about this it's like everywhere
you look almost it feels like you have
to deal with that that side of you that
maybe you've been avoiding and I think
that's necessary
was there anything scary about that yeah
yeah for sure
um so when I first took it I took a
little cup just so you guys know it's
like a little like brown liquid like in
a shot cup I took it I felt pretty
normal felt like a normal like mushroom
trip where I was like oh it's kind of
like I feel a sense of like well-being
and happiness and like trees are really
pretty and I walked around I was like
this is normal
and then I took another cub and then and
then like 35 minutes I just remember
almost like I was sitting there and I
remember blinking it was almost like
I know this isn't the way it works for
everyone because everyone's different
the way they react to this kind of
medicine but it was like imagine you
know what typical come up where you're
like oh I'm I'm getting I'm getting high
right you could feel it come up it was
like I had kind of like very mellow to
like there was no up I was just up and
then but it was weird because your
perception of time is completely altered
where like you don't have how long did
that happen I just remember blinking and
being like this is a lot and it felt
very uncomfortable because my thoughts
were like ping-ponging like like around
in my mind and I couldn't seem to like
hold one and just think of it yeah it
was like this and then this would come
and this would come and this would come
and it was all the things that I had
thought of kind of setting my intentions
leading up to it that I wanted to like
figure out but it felt like it was all
so much at one time and then eventually
it kind of slowly started to like come
apart
but it's not it's not a comfortable in
the sense of
I knew that I was there to do the work
to try to figure this out so I knew it
wasn't going to be like this is great
you know it was the thing where you're
you know you're you're in that moment
you're like well what am I really doing
and then I started thinking about death
and like when am I dying am I dying now
and then me thinking I'm gonna get stuck
in this moment yeah because you hear
about people who take stuff and like
because they're not doing it in the
right way or in the right manner with
the right reverence they end up in some
like weird space where like they're
altered forever and they're different
I'm like that's gonna be me that's me
I'm the guy every time I take
psychedelics yeah yeah no every time and
every time yeah straight up I don't
think that's real by the way what the
the that there's people that get this
idea that somebody had a bad trip though
yeah but so I was just afraid and it was
so it felt I think because of the the
medicine itself it felt so like
real it felt so like because your idea
of time is so miss like just gone that
it felt like you were there forever the
best way I can describe it in a bad way
in a moment in a moment yeah for for for
time and then and then Looking Back Now
it's like but then you also got to this
point where you're like okay now what
then and you kind of get calm in in the
idea that this is what it is and so
that's the thing that I'm looking for is
like I've been trying to find that calm
in the in the chaos the whole that's the
whole point of it right for me mentally
because I have my thoughts are so
sporadic all the time like what do I
have to do what am I getting done am I
doing enough is it enough am I enough
and then there comes a sense of calm
where you kind of just like
almost like it is what it is and I'm
gonna do my best and then it made me
realize that I needed to be better at
Living instead of thinking about dying
you know what I'm saying like I need to
be better at giving love and in showing
love because ultimately like what is all
this worth right this is cool this is
fun make money your cool clothing line I
have a cool clothing line we get to have
fun and talk and make content But
ultimately like life is just about love
giving it and receiving it because at
the end of the day you're not gonna be
like I wish I had more [ __ ] nice
things when you pass you're not going to
think about that you're going to think
about the love that you had the moments
that you had so I started to realize
that it was for me it was I needed to
be more present with giving and being
able to receive love without without the
fear of it's going to be taken away from
me because everything at some point is
going to be taken away from us like we
can't take this stuff with us nothing
right so I just kind of get more
comfortable in that fact and it just
kind of It kind of just makes you
remember that like very succinctly very
like instead of just knowing it you
really feel it
and that's the difference for me the
disconnect of like mentally like
cerebrally thinking something you're
feeling in your mind versus like
connecting it with what's in your body
and feeling that so I think it was
amazing man wow that sounds like yeah
incredible experience it's so it really
I just feel so bad for the um
it's just so tragic you know to see to
think of like the six-year-old who
questions like I wasn't good enough for
him to stay yeah like I I I hadn't
thought about it like in that terms
exactly and it's just it's so sad you
know because then you see I remember in
high school I remember like graduation I
remember I cried I cried all these big
moments where it was like you know you'd
want someone to see that because you see
all the other kids dads and you you
experience that and you're like why
don't I have that right like the
comparison but then you I mean now I
look back in my life and I understand
that comparison is like the worst thing
we could do in life in general
comparison is the thief of Joy yeah yeah
because it's a the thing that I think
that's it's really important for people
to hear and understand is that like no
one's life is supposed to be like this
picture-perfect thing and but we tend to
be taught that kind of stuff in Media or
like you know movies and Disney [ __ ] in
general and it's just kind of like it's
nothing is uh I don't mean it I didn't
mean to like attack Disney specifically
but in general like we're taught this
sorry sorry guys I love The Lion King
you're really gonna back I [ __ ] this I
mean [ __ ] but I like I like I like a
lot of the movies right but come on
Disney has like slaves and [ __ ]
Indonesia probably drawing cells with
their fingers bleeding probably you know
what I mean like they don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] true anyways but it just that's how
sweet you are you're like sorry sorry
I'm sorry I mean [ __ ] but but the
point is like uh we we we're all kind of
taught that life is supposed to be a
certain way and like I think you just
it's I don't know if we could teach
people not that life's gonna be [ __ ]
terrible or hard but it is also normal
for it to not be like sunshine of
rainbows all the time yeah because the
people who really truly find success are
are comfortable in like the non-success
part of it are able to deal with it
because that's how you get there right
so you don't just show up yeah you don't
just show up one day and be like I have
it yeah that my thing was like the chaos
or of it almost like destroyed me and I
feel like with creators in this in this
business you there's like a firewall in
a sense where it's like either you make
it past like a year or two of being like
successful yeah or you just disappear
because it's too [ __ ] hard and yeah I
almost disappeared this shit's not a
joke man I understand where you're
coming from when you talk about like the
burnout or like just like not being
happy and doing it because this is like
I've been doing [ __ ] for like 12 years
now 11 years it's like yeah it's a long
time it's uh Instagram socials and I
think YouTube I'm on like nine or ten
years yeah I'm about 10 years too yeah
it's crazy right but like but like
social in general I think probably 12
because I did Instagram first but
regardless it's just it's a lot and I
think people I I don't know because
people just see it for what it is but I
don't think they really understand like
what actually goes into it I think
people just looking at like oh you just
sit on a chair it looks easy it looks
fun you make a lot of money yeah you
know Rich successful people don't get
really to complain people don't really
empathize they're like oh well my life
[ __ ] sucks even more than yours
[ __ ] so I get it you know that's why
I get it but this [ __ ] is like a lot of
[ __ ] work
and a lot of expectations it's that yeah
for me the crushing part wasn't the work
itself it was the
dude the craziest thing about what we do
in my opinion is like the comments like
you are reading basically like intimate
conversations of people talking about
you without that the expectation that
you are going to be like standing behind
them listening to everything they're
saying and so it's almost like being
able to read people's minds you know
around you and hearing like their true
inner thought about you it's [ __ ] it's
me it's crazy yeah it's crazy talk about
the comments yeah yeah yeah yeah the
feedback
yeah then Twitter on YouTube so that was
a big hurdle for me to get over is kind
of like having a a more
uh concrete idea of self that is less
influenced by all the chirping going on
but I want to go back to the Ayahuasca
thing because I'm super interested on
like the actual experience so
you contact the shaman you you fly this
guy out does he speak English none no
English like very little English like
you can you know the kind of like you'd
show up somewhere and you just they
would kind of get what you're saying
because like the vibe yeah yeah yeah do
you guys are you working with a
translator or anything
no as Disney speaks Spanish or some like
weird Spanish but some of the stuff
because they would sing like little
songs and stuff were being like his like
native language which is not fully
Spanish it's like a like a derivative of
it right yeah so he and does he stay in
your house
he stayed in my house the night before
yeah okay yeah and so he brings this he
probably grows it right he brings yeah
they have a whole he can get busted if
he gets caught on the plane uh I don't I
know I don't think so I don't think it's
like a thing like that really I don't
know enough about like the legalities
dude that'd be kind of funny if is that
if they arrested the show I'm gonna put
his ass in jail but it's like you're
like damn it that sucks but also I just
wanted to take that [ __ ] I feel like I
feel like they don't really like TSA
does like they look for specific things
I feel like they're not looking they
wouldn't know what that was from yeah
they'd be like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah like they're looking for like tons
of bombs yeah yeah I don't know you
could say guns and bombs okay yeah
that's what they're looking for or like
knives I don't think they're looking for
like tins with [ __ ] liquid yeah yeah
I guess that one's a little hard to spot
it's not like a bag of cocaine when you
started filling it did you have to go
like to the bathroom a lot or no so
that's something so I I what I
understood about it was like this is a
it's a purgative so like you're supposed
to be throwing up or like [ __ ]
yeah I heard it makes people super
nauseous yeah no so okay this is the
thing this was really weird actually
um I took it and I'm sitting there and
for a second yeah it is bothering my
stomach I'm like this is like
it's kind of getting worse I remember
laying there and being like it's
actually getting a lot worse and then
the second that I didn't feel it at all
like it was like a switch it was right
when I started to feel it kick in so I
went from like my stomach really hurts
me like am I'm uncomfortable I'm
uncomfortable to like then I had this
like warm feeling go down my back and I
was like oh it's like it's starting to
kick in and then my stomach pain it
instantly disappeared and that's good
you got lucky I think yeah and then I
didn't throw up because normally do
people do throw up or they do like [ __ ]
their brains out yeah I saw a
documentary of a bunch of people doing
Ayahuasca and like in right I forget
what country they're in but they were
like in the jungle people coming in Peru
yeah maybe and they were all Yak in just
[ __ ] yeah so you're in so when you
guys sit down to actually start the
ceremony is it dark we got candles tell
me set the scene yeah okay so um he's
he's like he's gown he's like dressed up
so he has like a um you know like uh I'm
sure some sort of traditional like
outfit yeah like paint on his face uh he
has like a harmonica
he had like this like thing with leaves
that he was like shaking around you know
they like blessed the the yahi before we
drink it and all this stuff with like
tobacco so he's like smoking like these
like tobacco like cigarillos or whatever
would have been called
um and he has a bunch of beads on his
neck like a ton of bees and so he'll
have these like songs that he'll sing
and when he sings them you kind of like
feel like because of like the type of I
guess tune you feel a little bit higher
when it when it go when he starts to
sing interesting and like so the bees
are shaking and like you hear like he's
playing the harmonica and you're kind of
like oh that kind of hits you a little
harder okay and so this is the scene
though is like yeah it's it's it's
outside it's not crazy so he's got an
outfit he wears during the ceremony did
he show up like just with like jeans
yeah so he's like a totally normal dude
yeah a normal guy but then when the
Peyote comes out yeah well Ayahuasca or
the Iowa sorry it comes out it's and so
um he gives you the liquid
you guys can't communicate at all
what is he just like like well yeah I
knew what I knew what I was getting into
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like yeah it's
like you know are you ready and I'm like
drinking I'm looking I looked at it for
like I'm not gonna lie for like five
minutes and I was like am I ready
because I I have been all those fears
regarding it yeah I drink it it it
tastes terrible okay
um definitely not something I would
write home about but
um yeah I mean he's just it's like you
trip you out there's just random guy in
your house
oh really because I knew what I was
gonna do yeah you know I kind of knew
what it was I mean obviously like the
the I the thing that I was most worried
about was the communication right
because I'm like what if some what if
it's what if it's terrible yeah yeah
it's like yeah you know it's like I'm
because I know at one point I was
tripping I was crying like I was feeling
it yeah and he's like oh it's good it's
good yeah that's what happens every time
yeah it's good like normal yeah that
kind of stuff that's what he's saying
yeah okay so I'm like okay my keywords
yeah but in my mind I'm like do you
understand me but there was I'm not
gonna lie at one point I felt like I was
I was so deep in it that like a low-key
I could understand what he was saying oh
my God I understand full-on Spanish
that's funny
and um do you know how long it lasted
yeah actually which this is an
interesting thing it felt like it lasted
maybe like
maybe three hours oh [ __ ] that's short
no but but it didn't last three hours
yeah my perception of it was like if I
said if you asked me to when I was in it
how long has it been three hours but it
was nine to six o'clock that's a long
time whoa that's a long [ __ ]
time you're not even you have zero you
wouldn't even know that it was a long
time there's no like oh this is this is
a really long time wow you don't even
think about time and is he sober does he
drink he drinks a bit oh so he's on one
from his own Supply yeah that's part of
the process you gotta be on the same
wavelength as you a little bit yeah
exactly
and so how much you pay this guy to come
out
flight aside like what's his fee 2500.
damn that guy's doing good up there yeah
but so you could do it in a way where
you could have multiple people involved
in it but I was just like I knew I would
have been comfortable in that situation
just because I knew that I'd probably be
there crying and I was like I don't want
all these people watching me yeah
um which is ironic because I cry on the
[ __ ] internet all the time apparently
but I just didn't want I didn't know I
didn't I didn't know what to expect from
the thing but I'm gonna be saying crazy
[ __ ] like I don't want someone to be
like that's a personal yeah yeah so
that's good though I'm glad it came out
you came out the other side with a
positive experience really really
positive
haha that's lit yo who did that real
quick yeah that's one of our guys I lost
the king that's dope yeah that was in
Dubai dude oh yeah that's a great edit
good stuff that's our man can back there
um would you ever do Ayahuasca I mean
you'd have to get the thing is I prefer
to stay on my antidepressants if I
wasn't I'd try all that [ __ ] yeah you
know I mean it kind of reminds me of one
of our acid trips a long a long time ago
yeah I mean a similar psychedelics it
was bad the acid trip was that bad
what's the worst part I haven't even
done acid yet bro it was like a blank
it's almost like a blank slate like we
were high for like 15 hours and so my
friend game I think we've told the story
yeah but my friend gave me a vial
and he said there's only two hits in it
he already used it and everybody said it
was really um light it wasn't too strong
didn't have to do it wasn't true so I
took the vial I put a two piece of paper
was like
and I can only imagine how much was
actually on that oh you took a lot and
he was like let's just finish the bottle
whatever
yeah no that's he said he gave us the
vial and he said just finish it that
should be the perfect amount for the two
of you yeah okay bro and if we were and
our friends before it would be there
like oh it was totally true it was it
wasn't too strong it was a nightmare 15
hours both of it was bad for both of you
yeah it was just the two of us it was
freezing and but it was kind of like you
were describing or like every second
like didn't mean anything like there was
no concept of time yeah dude and I I'm
the one that goes like [ __ ] non-stop
when it starts
when I start to feel it and then I'm I
know like okay it's happening yeah it's
happening
yeah good for you though man I'm glad
I'm very pro drug use I'm very Pro uh
like responsible yeah yeah I think it's
all it was all great experiments like as
far life experience like I I absolutely
I had it and like I'm happy we did it
yeah I'm a big fan yeah is there anyway
I know we're live is anybody can use the
bathroom yeah yeah we do it all the time
okay it's right past that you know you
know what it is right yeah
no no no take your time it's okay how
bad do you have to pee right now
apparently really bad
but I do that all the time so um we
gotta get back to the meat it's starting
to drip on the table I was gonna ask you
about that
[Laughter]
yeah
uh story you just told I don't know if
you ever have told that story on the
show because I don't remember I'll tell
it I thought I just thought people it
was one of those things people get all
annoyed they go Ethan just tells the
same stories over and over so I was like
I'm not gonna tell the story don't pull
if I told the story yes or no we
definitely did I mean you've definitely
mentioned that but I don't know if I
just knew you took that much okay could
you maybe tell the story on Andrew's
podcast
um all gas no break channel five Andrew
oh maybe maybe it was on someone else I
don't know we'll see if everyone
remembers it or not
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro
yeah okay so so
let's see if the audience remembers or
not
as Ethan told the vile story before
uh 28 say they remember it but the
majority say no no it was on another
podcast or something there wasn't that
much more to it we got super [ __ ]
high every second was like fragmented
like each minute was like sliced into 60
pieces and there was no like connection
between them and we will just kind of
like stare at each other and we like
couldn't even talk we would want to say
something and couldn't even talk we
couldn't talk to each other we were like
I think at one point we were like let's
try to listen to music and then we
couldn't even figure out how to do that
sounded bad I hated it and and I tried
Skyrim had just came out and I was like
I just need something I just need
something to ground me right now and I
get on Skyrim and I'm just riding my
horse straight for hours just [ __ ] it
is so bad man you've had but you've had
good psychedelics yeah yeah yeah we did
mushrooms great yeah I don't know if you
consider MDMA psychedelic but we hadn't
always positive really good experiences
on the MDMA whose idea was it to put the
cheetah while you pee right right where
the pisser is wasn't that here when we
bought the place is that here oh yeah
the cheating like the Michael Jackson
Thriller yeah that was here yeah it's
been here okay let's watch this all
right let's do it we've come a long way
already though yeah yes so um regarding
the gym thing because as you related to
laser tag don't forget that okay so
maybe I can explain that okay I know
that the latest that was the wild part I
was like what the [ __ ] so so my point
was
is that I I understand how important the
gym is to right yeah
I think my point was is that different
people's Hobbies can be meaning have
that same meaningfulness to them maybe
your a laser tag was obviously a I tried
to find like the most absurd thing to
say if someone's obvious for comedy but
it could be anything you know it could
be like golf it could be basketball it
could be whatever uh it has has that
special meaning to them right and so a
lot of people at the time were being
asked to give up to sacrifice those
hobbies to prevent the spread of the
disease and so that that's what I meant
that being said you know
um
I get it do you want I I think it's you
you made a stand for yourself and I
think that's cool actually what you
ended up doing the part that like you
know I think ultimately is what got me
going a little bit was like this kind of
stuff you know
um
come on Brad I don't do that [ __ ] that's
that's free Donnie dude that's that's
Jim should be oh it should have been
open though and they realized but you
could have like had people ass yeah
everything but I mean you know the gym
is kind of like the worst place no cause
everybody's breathing for spreading she
means for spreading yeah
well I don't know if they've actually
proved that though because there's no
actual proof of that well I think it's
just like because you're breathing yeah
but also the gym was a place that like
at the same time like the stars the
health benefits of working out yeah they
proved that was essential to you not
dying from Cohen right so it wasn't just
like uh
yeah apparently it's not just a hobby
thing it was also like a health thing
yeah but you can you can do a trim you
can exercise at home yeah sure but what
if you didn't know how to do it properly
like you had a trainer I think I
wouldn't I think I don't think I would
have been I actually did sessions over
Zoom during coven
ants were you with them
well that's like a me issue but like I
said so that's what I'm saying but I
feel like I wouldn't have gotten so mad
if like in the gym you guys were like at
least having some precautions to prevent
the spread well you guys were like [ __ ]
it well I had two
uh eleven thousand dollar [ __ ] air
purifier system things that were like
actually really really high quality yeah
um and we did actually I mean we have
flowing air like we had the big bay door
thing oh we did all that kind of [ __ ]
from this this shot was from the bay
door at least one grandma died from this
no dude I'm just saying statistically
the free Bill Cosby guy's grandma died
I'm sure that's just hilarious because
obviously it is funny stupid
this is a good picture though man where
was I do you guys gonna get the one with
me standing on the thing there's gonna
have you want me standing on the thing
me and Steve
yeah there's not a single woman in that
crowd you guys are awesome I'll never
forget that yeah so I mean listen at the
time it was like well I mean [ __ ] this
guy we're all making sacrifices and it
just felt like a little bit but that
that's what it was and you know covet it
was a crazy time and everyone [ __ ]
kind of like had a hard time with it
right so I I'm not in retrospect I'm not
I'm not judging you at all and uh you
know you do what you had to do fair and
I think uh and I you know I respect you
and yeah okay
you got to give it one too and do you
forgive me for comparing Jim to laser
tag yes
that was mainly it yeah
that would piss me the [ __ ] off but you
know
those people tag just as much as you
love the gym maybe they live oh you know
there's people out there that love
they're probably in America and then do
you forgive me for um
for saying that working out to waste of
time I do but I don't know if the whole
gym Community will okay but I will I
will I will represent them I will
represent the gym Community we should we
should forgive Ethan because I exercise
yeah I exercise yeah yeah it's a
misunderstanding and I forgive you for
lying about uh Steve jerking off his dog
bro I know he did I swear
I swear let's squash the [ __ ] out of
this beef so before before we did that
podcast we literally were talking about
how we were gonna make
we were gonna make it funny by just
adding random [ __ ] even the stuff about
like his girl and all the [ __ ] that he
said in the podcast this is when we were
in Miami when we talked about it
um the point was to make it a joke no
leave it that's beautiful okay okay I
already know where you're going with
this where am I going you're gonna say
why was he mad no that's not what I'm
going no okay we'll get there go ahead
Donnie no I get why he'd be mad if he
made it up nobody wants to be accused of
bestiality you guys took it far but it's
funny I you know what I I mean listen we
took it all the way the whole thing was
fun in my opinion okay so so I'm gonna
I'm gonna take you at your word
that he didn't actually jerk off his dog
I know I'm a TR I'm gonna say you were
there I wasn't even there you guys
planned it but there was a lot of
details about scooping and cows funny
okay okay because listen listen that's a
joke oh my God he was so and then so the
one thing I want to say is y'all can't
blame me because in the comments
everybody was like Steve jerks off his
dog and I was and then even when you
guys were like it's a joke I can't
believe Ethan actually thought it was
real all the comments who are your fans
not even mine those people all hate
where is where is that other guy
um Hassan where is Hassan for this
because I feel like he was a part of
this conversation I thought he was going
to be here today oh no he's not here
okay anyways he's here on Thursdays we
have a differential was he I don't think
he was and he talked about this I saw a
clip talking about this anyway didn't
address him he's probably not streaming
right now to watch so so uh so so the
thing with the thing with Steve was like
Illustrated was just a joke we thought
about it we planned it out prior
um I understand why like you're thinking
like oh he's he's a upset about the
reaction to it you're talking about the
fans but he like we like that's what he
just makes dumbass jokes like that's
that's his that's his character that's
what he's done people are saying it was
way too detailed
to be made up that's good comedy he's a
genius you got to think about it too so
but why would you because that's like me
coming out here and being like yeah so
uh I'm being over the top so don't no go
ahead I would say like yeah so uh
there's this crazy time where you know I
uh had sex with a kid and uh
great things about how he jerks off his
dog as a joke you got to at least say
you're kidding why would you want people
to think you're about the animals and
yeah obviously that was a that I was
trying to make a point obviously I don't
[ __ ] kids okay
I don't know if that needs to be said
um that clip yeah the zoo culture be
like where's Ethan saying I feel good
you're done holy [ __ ] uh no no so here's
the thing right okay you understand the
power of social media right you make
content about other people's content
you've done it for years no yeah yeah so
and US knowing it's not a rookie he's
not a rookie either I'm not a rookie
either we knew that people would be like
oh this is this is not that that
specifically thing was like we're gonna
take that the farthest but we knew that
people would be like what like even the
James Harden thing and talking about his
girl like she he dm'd her and like this
joke around this like we knew that there
would be a a reaction to it and you
honestly just made the episode better
because you came and you talked and you
caused more traction he goes I [ __ ]
hate Ethan Klein when he was doing the
Andrew tape thing on Rumble he's like I
[ __ ] hate him like he he wants me to
even kill me no he wanted to kill you no
I don't think he's violent I'm just
kidding but he hates me I I mean I don't
really know I'd like to get him here I'd
love to get him here that would be a
[ __ ] funny episode because then I
think you'd see I think you'd see how
actually like genuine and like real he
is too it is comedy he probably just
felt the certain way because people find
him funny I think he's funny people came
to attack him about it because your fan
base is obviously strong no but all but
I gotta say again and remember that girl
drove by Me was like Brad and Steve jerk
off dog so she they're a little violent
dude fans are like I'm surprised that's
pretty unusual I gotta say first in 12
years that's never happened that's kind
of amazing whoever you are I got it I've
been mad yeah I'm not even mad it was it
was honestly really funny
uh but but I just want to say I'm
getting a little bit too much
um blame because in the comments we're
like yo what the [ __ ] and then when you
guys made a second episode being like I
can't believe Ethan believed that
all the comments and I know y'all read
them was like nah [ __ ] that Steve
definitely jerked his dog
[Laughter]
fan don't don't get I'm saying it's just
a little he can't get mad at me when
your own fans are like nah he did it
that's funny it is funny that's why I
[ __ ] talk about it all the time oh
it's hilarious yeah I want you to do I
wish Steve was here I wish he was here
man I wish Donnie was here well you bet
you do I bet you hey yeah
[ __ ] dude holy [ __ ] so there it is okay
let's do a poll do you think Steve
jerked off his dog yes or no 100 no I
know he did he says no and he was there
Brad I lived with him for like three
months you never saw the doctor's dogs
no I'll tell you one time so this is
this is another no no no no no no no
yeah that's not what I'm saying don't
cut that [ __ ] that listen don't start
the pool yet not that never happened but
there was I'm gonna tell you a true
story this is a true story
one time Selena Selena I think was
FaceTiming Steve and was like yo look
what Donny's doing and then it was like
Donnie was like he must have had a hard
on because he was humping a pillow and I
think he screenshotted that like
FaceTime and was like look this is
hilarious that was it why are you
telling that story was it public or
something no that's just that stuff so
he's making animal pornography oh Jesus
bro it's not animal pornography what the
hell I'm just kidding no all right so
Ethan do you want my son to call in oh
his son can call in he's he he streams
so he always does this is he stream
right now yeah he's on Twitch he's
always streaming so he can call in
because he's probably watching right
whenever we mention him everyone in his
audience like Ethan talking and then he
pulls it up oh yeah okay so just guys as
you're voting remember Bradley was there
he's friends with them they planned this
he's saying this did not happen it
didn't happen and I believe you I
believe you because we're dogs now yeah
did not yes I get why it's funny though
yeah yeah so the votes are in 6 000
votes cast 90 everyone hold on
everyone's gonna say I knew it though is
that on Twitter no it's on the light
YouTube live okay of course I mean
that's the internet I love that kind of
90 say Steve jerked his dog off oh 90
that's a blowout I mean we can't rely on
them to give the truth right they're
just giving their opinion their opinion
the truth frankly is between uh Steve
and Donnie Donny and God
[Laughter]
that's funny that's what I'm talking
about you want me to get him on the line
what did you want to ask him sure just
about the you want to tell him it's it
was I don't even care honestly but if he
wants hop on [ __ ] yeah you can cop we
got to tell Hassan and his audience
Steve will do it did not take off his
dog yeah ask his audience his audience
is gonna I already know we call him
Steve will Jerk it yeah I heard yeah
yeah
or Steve Steve you gotta have him on man
I'd love to I'd love to maybe but he
said he wouldn't talk to a fat guy and
an ugly girl maybe I need to lose a
little bit more weight he's on his way
down and also if I don't know if ELO's
too ugly I might need to get some Botox
yeah by the way his girlfriend's lovey
very nice girl yeah
yeah you guys should come together so
that we have like a neutral I would yeah
and I'll lose some weight and I'll
apologize for being back maybe like if
you just start the podcast like working
out or something oh yeah sure I could do
that yeah I started to apologize after
you know the gym guys got on me and I
just became like the fat guy I like to
apologize for being fat people actually
I'm sorry I didn't open for apologizing
yeah I'm actually kind of disrespecting
you to start with I apologize for being
over with be sorry yeah
the regret steel holy [ __ ] yeah
um okay well there it is Steve did not
jerk his dog off guys and stop [ __ ]
saying that slanderous lie yeah it's
[ __ ] straight up
now I know where this place is yeah yeah
yeah so when you exercise
do you do what's the number oh how much
you bench yeah wow the most it's got to
be the most common Gym Bro question
you've ever asked
um
I mean currently I probably work around
like 3 15 to like 4 55 if I'm benching
pounds 3 15 to 4. huge range yeah well
it's like I'm not I'm not actually like
training to be necessarily any stronger
than I already am
um oh this phone's here
into the fitness but what if you're just
doing like um like this kind of stuff
like girls or I mean it ranges like
sometimes I just try to get a pump
sometimes I'll try and like lift heavy
it really just yeah so if you're just
trying to get a pump uh casual lifting
casual yeah get a pump in 65 pounds
maybe look at this look at his biceps
that's crazy all right Hassan you're
being called out we have Bradley Martin
here well I don't know about calling I'm
just kidding Zoo culture let's go the
zoo man himself
into exercise so he expects the the
hustle that's good yeah so we're here to
talk about Steve will do it he did not
jerk off his dog we want you and all of
your audience to know that it's a slam
yeah and he that dog there was no how is
he valuing us right now
and he's live on Twitter live on Twitch
yeah damn that's that's that's [ __ ]
that's good quality we got that we got
all the time wait wait hold up so I have
some questions for Bradley Bradley you
said that you guys had a conversation
ahead of time to like make a joke about
this is that true yeah yeah
see okay so you guys were uh you guys
were like let's do a joke and then the
joke was that Steve will do it we'll
jerk off his dog
it's a [ __ ] joke yeah but but the
joke the but the punch line can't be oh
yeah I'm a murderer or oh I'm a
pedophile like like it's it's not a good
thing to be you know what I mean like
you gotta at least say I'm it's a joke I
mean it's not real it's not the worst
yeah I know it's not real but everyone
thought it was right and also like that
I mean if you look at the kind of
content that we've made over years it's
like it's not the most okay you know
yeah so that's the thing too it's like
also understanding all of it right like
like when I came in here to you and I
said hey these are my three experiences
with you right they're all negative
right but do you make only negative
content uh 90 okay okay well I'm just
kidding but it's like not right so it's
like your perception it's just it's just
based on that my perception is based on
that yeah you watch all the content you
understand okay Steve just kind of he
[ __ ] off a lot he makes that [ __ ]
up for example when I jerk off Donnie
yeah but but so let me get let me just
uh probe a little bit so you guys before
the show got together and then I want to
know how detailed so so he said I'm
gonna tell you I got my dog off we were
talking about no we were talking about
it yeah yeah yeah so you specifically
made that plan yep okay okay yeah and
then there was like three current things
you want to talk about like three joke
topics we want to talk about okay there
it is you see so why do you think I'm
like like what how far down on the line
was the the jerking off the dog though
like was it first like oh let's do like
uh like a fart joke and then and then
Steve was like nah I actually jerk off
my dog and that's really important no
like I said like I told you earlier the
uh that uh that FaceTime thing it was in
relationship to that like that this dog
like was humping a pillow or something
okay so then it's like their head was
history there yes yeah
because he started off by saying he's
getting [ __ ] all over the house and yeah
jerk them off because there's no way I I
want here I'll defend Steve actually the
detail about watching Disney movies no
but that's funny jokes that's hilarious
like who's he's also talking like he the
thing like he Blends a little real like
realism into it right so much really
talked about getting IVs which he gets
IVs all the time yeah while he's like
doing it but he's focused on this it's
like a joke it's [ __ ] I think the
watching the lady in the [ __ ] while
jerking off your dog gives credit being
a joke that being said we have 12 000
votes cast 90 of people are saying Steve
jerked off his
dog's dog off be honest be honest no
they're both saying no
yeah like if you know him you'd get it
yeah these two guys behind the scene
here you guys work with Steve
oh but but you got so you guys know yeah
we're all around yeah yeah so they're
saying they know Steve he definitely
didn't jerk his dog
it seems a very unique individual for
sure you gotta you gotta read it he's
like he says reckless [ __ ] he says crazy
[ __ ] yeah but it's [ __ ] it's from a
good place people are saying Bradley is
lying no not mine at all I'm just I
totally believe you I believe you man
yeah it kind of explains everything I
feel like he doesn't believe me though
John do you believe this I'm I'm not
gonna lie dude he's not that good at
like he's not that good of an actor
right like he felt too detailed like
that was my thing like how was he so
good at acting and Bradley you are Oscar
winning performance if you if you
literally like planned this ahead of
time you're like you're the male Meryl
Streep yo thank you really because
you're like what are we talking about
here good bro but I've been have you
looked like I said if you looked at
content we made for time like for
example there's a video where I get I
get I get uh uh [ __ ] electric like
shocked I think he actually get shocked
do you think I actually would agree to
get [ __ ] shocked there's a ton of
videos we've made that it's like it's
it's a little bit of satire you know
it's not [ __ ] it's not real not all of
it's real but like it's it's because
it's [ __ ] funny you know what bro out
of respect for you and the beef we
squash yeah I think we're dogs now let's
say yeah right yeah
I'm gonna say this didn't happen and
Hassan I don't want to hear it anymore
yeah no I will never bring it up uh wait
so what is I'm sure you guys talked
about this but I have to bring it up I'm
sorry for asking this but uh what does
Bradley think about the liver King Saga
oh we didn't even get to talk about that
you're going to we've been talking about
all kinds of other stuff yeah that man
made me eat penis
he shouted wait you were there he was
there on that one yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I I
[ __ ] bull Tesco's and all that stuff
too it was pretty good same thing I did
I like the marrow did you try the marrow
uh the bone marrow it was like the
butter love the bone yeah we did we shot
it but I've also had it for personal
pleasure uh many times it's more
cultured than here like for real yeah oh
that's dope yeah I mean it's actually
really good for you but no the liver
King thing's it's it's interesting I
mean do you think so so you're part of
the zoo culture uh as they say me too
yeah he's a zoologist I'm a zoo head
azua file isn't that the term animals no
no no
foreign
so that's interesting that's an
interesting Venn diagram he's got
zoophile and Zoo culture yeah maybe it's
just a method actor you know and he
really took the role the dude's really
funny
the heart
he loves Jeffrey Dahmer we know that
about him 13
000 votes are in uh 90 say he did it
guys stop it's not playing anymore
yeah oh wait I have a question for
Bradley Bradley do you think someone can
maintain a like five percent body fat
like that year round uh without the
usage of of like heavy cycling steroids
and HGH and numerous other things that
he had in a stack we talk about like the
idea of heavy right yeah I mean what he
had was extreme like can can someone do
it without a heavy usage of Something
I'm assuming so yeah she's saying like I
mean but like still you have to like
push it to the Limit right uh I don't
think so to be that I mean some people
just genetically are more gifted than
others for sure because I know girls I
know guys that like I know for certain
that they're natural right but they
still look incredible where it's like
damn it I think damn if that person got
on any sort of anything they would look
insane but by by natural they still look
crazy so everyone is so uniquely
different to this did you know uh liver
was on uh steroids yeah was it obvious
to you obvious yeah I mean I did I
talked to him on my podcast about it I
saw you you were like what's up dude
you're on stereo yeah I mean it's just
like to that it's it's more so like the
degree of like I don't know how thick
the veins are how thin the skin is like
it's not that's not like a natural thing
for most people right some people could
have more of that than others like I
said it's hard to say exactly because
everyone is so different and everyone
responds to like that stuff differently
as well we're talking about steroids
right
um but I mean it looked pretty apparent
it looked very apparent just because of
the nature of like the vascularity and
the leanness all that [ __ ] everything
can consider so does someone need to
take a crazy amount ounce to be like
that not necessarily so do you think
it's ethical for him because what he was
doing is like yo buy my supplements I'm
all natural it's the liver it's the bone
marrow it's whatever the [ __ ] sleeping
on wooden boards is it ethical for him
to lie I mean it's not ethical obviously
no like and there I think I know there's
a big debate like in gym culture about
like
uh being upfront about if you're taking
something or not because people look at
certain types of bodies and say is that
achievable how do I do that yeah and
they get the wrong idea like why don't I
look like that if they're not taking
anything yeah I mean it's like in my
opinion it's like if you don't want to
talk about it don't talk about it but
don't tell everyone I'm natural yeah
right this is then you know what I'm
saying because he he went on a few
different podcasts saying and all the
times yeah I do yeah yeah you said it on
ours and he actually I've even seen him
get angry when people ask him he's like
yo I'm [ __ ] like so I just want to
preface this and say this it's like for
the for the liver King thing it's also
it's it sucks because he also had like
actual good message yeah and then that's
all going to get like just pushed to the
Wayside now just because he said so many
times I'm natural I'm natural I'm
natural and then they related to the
fact that well you have these big
supplement companies so then you're kind
of convincing people that they can look
like you with without that when you have
that and then you just sell them this
and and then it's like the thing that he
actually there's a lot of value was like
the actual
um the other things like getting Sun
working out like the other ideas and the
mentality behind like his like tenant
thing that he's created but like there
are there is valuable stuff there but
like the way it was all delivered was it
was [ __ ] up yeah but so so like I hear
people say that a lot like after
something goes sideways uh they say it
let's just use liver King for example so
don't have to [ __ ] on anyone else
but like the other stuff that's good
everybody else is saying that yeah you
say that [ __ ] absolutely and so but what
set him apart was the [ __ ] that he was
lying about it was his crazy body and
him his career well he's he's a showman
too yeah it was also the whole eating
the Raw Liver thing the raw yeah so he
had he had a good stick but all the
stuff you're saying that's like you know
that was good I mean there's plenty of
people who are saying that and I think
what put him over the top was the LIE
yeah it's unfortunate yeah I think I
think one of the other things that most
people do not understand is that like
even if you did his exact stack I'm glad
you said never looked like him yeah you
would not look like him unless you also
worked out twice a day like he did and
like work third uh you know walk 13
miles on your rest day like he is
obsessive it definitely has a lot of
body dysmorphia as well like clearly
from those messages I'm glad you're
saying this though too because it is
relevant like I do think people go so
and I think that's why people are afraid
of talking about it in general because
they just think someone's just going to
just say well you'll have this just
because of that right because people's
naturally mentality play your hard work
yeah because but it is true I know
people who've taken tons of [ __ ] and
look like you wouldn't even guess that
they ever took it once so it's like
there is like there is a level that
people they just kind of like I guess
they're afraid of that attack of like oh
this [ __ ] isn't it's not worth anything
because you did that and they just kind
of take it away just like you know we
talk about like pro sports like Jerry
Maguire like he took steroids right and
but it's like those steroids aren't
going to teach you how to hit a bat you
know what I'm saying like you're not
going to be yeah maybe you hit if you're
good at hitting you'll hit that you'll
excuse me hit a ball right you're gonna
hit that harder but like I if I can get
a bunch of steroids I'm not gonna
[ __ ] hit a bat I'm not going to be
able to [ __ ] bat out you know home
run because I can't even hit the ball
but Jerry Maguire would have never broke
the record without steroids fire yeah no
absolutely that dude had the record for
like one day Mark McGuire sorry Mark
McGuire
anyway he broke the record for like a
day you know my bad yeah but the point
is like it's it doesn't just like I mean
with bodybuilding and like physique it
is a little bit more specific but like
forever people have done that like oh
you took steroids like you're you ain't
[ __ ] and I'm I'm willing to bet 99 of
people in professional sports are on
steroids some form of steroids they're
not necessarily taking bodybuilding
servers trying to be like a jacked
bodybuilder but all of them are taking
something because you got to think at
the highest level I'm talking about like
LeBron James all these people if they're
if they're LeBron James spends like what
a million something dollars a year on
his just his health it's like if their
whole entire livelihood is based around
how they perform then they would take
things down in every Edge yeah and it's
like I think people just like don't
think about it and they just go oh it
just knocks they're playing basketball
okay maybe not LeBron James he's lagot
uh so I don't agree with that
this man
I love it no I'm not saying he's not
great I'm just saying like I have no
problem with steroid use I think it's
fine you know I think I think I
personally I think all drugs should be
legal everything on a stack please I'm
trying I'm trying so hard I want him to
do like I want him to do steroids and
get me looking yeah dude I don't have to
do like don't have to like do something
first like that you're cutting it like
let me just like get skinny or like you
know I mean lose my fat and then we
could talk about steroids well I mean
steroids
hormone bro does that make your dick
bigger
makes everything else you're stupid
it does make it does make a lot of other
functions in your body just more
efficient likewise your skin collagen
synthesis all all synthesis so like yeah
blood flow might be a little bit better
so maybe Dick's a little stronger okay
we like that yeah that's solid yeah it's
a good thing what you were saying though
it makes your heart bigger too though
yeah
I don't want heart I want only dick
bigger and heart stay nice and tight
there's supplements for the hard thing
you know I want a petite beautiful
[ __ ] little heart
[Laughter]
you don't want that to get too big no
and by the way 16 000 votes 90 say yes
Steve jerked his dog off guys stop
it's not funny well of course they're
gonna say that
yeah but the internet always picks the
negative guys it's not funny it's not
cute Bradley's here he's saying it
didn't happen yeah Steve did not jerk
that dog off he took a picture of the
dog humping something but that's it yes
yeah Hassan why do you think LeBron is
not on uh steroids because he's the goat
is that it yeah that's it okay fair fair
he's infallible and he can't do no wrong
oh my god dude I think he's great too I
just think like why not I think you're
right at a certain point and you know
the Lance Armstrong thing was really
nuts but it turns out that all of his
contemporaries the people who were like
competing with them they're all on
steroids too so it's just a weird thing
it's like everyone needs to be on it or
nobody needs to be on it because it's
not fair when he's on it and nobody else
is that transparency yeah or just if
they're gonna do it like just if
someone's choosing to do it in that in a
sport let them do it but it's like then
but that's the thing it's gonna it's
gonna make everyone feel like they have
to do it because to get to a level right
because if you're competing with people
who are competitive then it's like you
can't be on the same level if it's and
it kind of sucks where it's like oh if
you want to be a professional athlete
then all of a sudden you got to be
taking some these kinds of drugs that
may not be good for your health yeah and
it becomes like an ethical thing it's
just it's a weird tricky I'm sure that's
why it isn't that way yeah yeah that
makes sense even though I'm sure plenty
of the people are more than willing to
do it for yeah for the advantage and
there's healthy ways to go about all
this kind of stuff it's a matter of like
blood work like checking all that stuff
and but actually I believe it should be
legalized and there should be better
medical technology and better checks to
ensure that people can safely inject
steroids in the way that they're
currently doing already so that I can
finally get some [ __ ] awesome
steroids are you looking for juice I
agree I mean you could just go to
foreign
why do you want to do it is it just
Aesthetics like what is the reason well
I mean I'll probably do it if uh I'll
probably do it if I get to like a
certain level like when I'm 35 or
whatever when I start noticing that my T
levels are decreasing or whatever
testosterone levels testosterone levels
and then well what happens when your T
levels Get Low you get depressed you get
sad you lose make more body fat have a
harder time sleeping the sauce one is a
very important thing wouldn't that
doctor just give you they'll give you
testosterone if you're low I mean
technically he can go and get that
prescribed to him right now if he wanted
to yeah what are you waiting for there's
doctors that'll give it to you like
turkesterone and stuff like that too
like a pretty common a lot of people do
it in in Hollywood Walter kesterone is
[ __ ] that's just a supplement
we're talking about testosterone yeah
I'm just saying that there's like
different way different things that you
can take uh already that's like even
over the counter yeah there's some yeah
it's just I would say nothing really
amounts to what testosterone does though
I want to ask you so even just
not like even trt itself is not like uh
like you know stacking up happens to the
liver King was taken yeah well no no not
even close trt's like the amounts would
be like 125 to you know 200 maybe at the
most milligrams of this a week where I
think he was doing like excessive
amounts of what go ahead sorry you got
cut off there I was gonna say like kind
of like how you were about the
antidepressant where you're like isn't
just natural better yeah I kind of have
the same reaction right now like but
don't you want to just go natural yeah
so so some I mean obviously you can I
mean some people can some people do I
think I think what's been happening
though it seems like overall like you
know water people drink food people eat
all this stuff is adding like the
environment is adding like stress on the
human body that maybe wasn't as
necessarily as normal in the past so
that's why you know even the liver King
is talking about these certain tenets
and things to do like turn your phone
off and get out and go in the sun and do
these things it's like you're trying to
optimize yourself naturally but if you
have so many stressors that are making
it harder for that to happen then like
this would be an option for someone who
couldn't change all these
you know parts of their life to make
themselves optimal to like then just
bring it to a level that's that's still
optimal for them to be healthy that'd be
like what's trt would be because like
having sub levels is actually also more
detrimental to your health than you know
just not doing it at all not taking care
of it at all it's actually worse for you
because in your body's ability to
respond to cortisol is lessened your
sleep will be [ __ ] up and it's just a
myriad of things that just get worse and
worse so it really depends I mean
there's so many other things you can do
like instead of that right to optimize
yourself but for some people maybe it's
just not enough like you were talking
about you could have tried all these
things instead of taking the thing and
then you're like okay well I kind of got
to the point where I tried it I I
exhausted all my options now I want to
try it yeah the same sort of thing yeah
I want to ask you because I don't know
this is crazy and it seems crazy but
well there are two peptides so let's
start from here so I don't know what igf
is like is this are the dosage amount
insane too well I don't even see the
dosage well I've been taking for a year
there's no dosage there yeah so well
this no his test this is not I mean yeah
the test deck and winstraw do you know
all these drugs because some of them are
like crazy experimental it sounded like
no the first two are like
igf-1 CJC these are like peptides and
yes the zoo culture subscription none of
this [ __ ] dude wait a lot of this [ __ ]
wait what how much wait it's cold out a
little bit because one of this says how
much he takes yeah but would you ever do
like a zoo culture like a monthly box
with steroids
it's highly illegal yeah yeah I know I
can't do that highly illegal but also
brilliant yeah yeah I mean bro I mean he
does it's more like I would have to
party with like a HRT clinic or
something like that I know people me too
make a lot of money yeah my blood sugar
levels are out okay well where does he
say the actual amounts oh wait I mean
5.3
you scroll into the middle section
five milligram vials how much have you
taken go scroll tell it this side 11 000
yeah which is four vials 16 vials a
month whoa is that a lot see that's a
good amount yeah that's holy [ __ ]
because he was spending like twelve
thousand dollars a month which is seems
crazy right well growth hormones also
just very expensive okay very expensive
that's the most expensive thing on that
but yeah I mean it's his damn yeah our
boy was juicing okay now guys I just
want to say 18 000. sorry go ahead son
go ahead I was used to it was a question
I was gonna ask and this is the last
thing I'll ask is uh because you know I
won't take uh any more time how much do
you think that shaves off your life
expectancy damn like that that stack I
mean that's it's really hard to quantify
it's the same thing like how much do
these things affect anyone 64. yeah we
don't know like you can't really know
that answer right like there could be so
many other things that he's doing
outside of that that are also like
counteracting it or trying to counteract
it to keep him healthier
he was taking not only his own ancestral
liver supplements but he was also taking
additional liver supplements on top of
that because of the damage that the his
stack was doing yeah like there's like
the protective there's a lot of stuff
that you can take to like counteract the
effects of it right where you're trying
to like basically get ahead of the fire
right but so it really just depends like
there's just certain supplements was he
taking them I don't know I don't know
any data on it but I can't say it's
really hard to say what time someone
would die obviously I mean I almost had
their blood work and [ __ ] I will say
livers apology video was I didn't see it
oh you didn't yeah because it just came
out what yesterday yeah I didn't see it
it was nice did you see it just owned it
like big time I haven't watched it yet
it was about to wait what let's watch it
yeah I want to watch it for real I'll
pull it up you want to watch it together
yeah let's watch this yeah I thought it
was good actually I thought it was
refreshing to see someone like
completely and utterly own
their mistake
um it's not long so I think we'll be
fine to watch it here oh yeah
and just let me know if you want me to
pause it so I mean this is going viral
too it's like everywhere yeah what
happened is everywhere I think the
problem with liver had was that he got
too [ __ ] big I don't think he ever
expected to get like he became like
[ __ ] huge everyone talking about
liver King even the makeup girl this
morning was talking about it really like
everybody's talking about you know it
went viral outside of the fitness yeah
that's the thing yeah
what the fitness people think of liver
King before all this or just before I
mean I think people kind of knew right
so it's like a lot of people Kim did
they respect him like what was the con
did they have thoughts about liver
cancer I mean I mean I met him he was
nice like I just it's I was you know I
expected him of using though a lot of
people suspected him of being on gear
for sure yeah I mean you know you know
right away I just like here is liver
King
I think he's Brian now let's be honest
now he's Brian now he's Brian Johnson
threw him up because he told me he ate
that guy or something right I told Brian
Johnson yeah he just he just yaked him
out because this is Brian let's see I'm
excited can you turn it up a bit
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
because I lied
and I misled a lot
I stated that this is a complicated as
[ __ ] Topic at least to me it is because
before social media I was rich and
Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer Anonymous and I
never expected this kind of exposure in
the public eye
it's been tricky as [ __ ] to navigate
well
clearly I did it wrong and I'm here now
to set the record straight
yes I've done steroids and yes I am on
steroids monitored and managed by
trained hormone clinician
liver King the public figure was an
experiment to spread the message to
bring awareness to the 4 000 people a
day who kill themselves that 80 000
people a day that try to kill themselves
I thought that was a little corny yeah
like I take steroids because there's
people who are depressed yeah yeah come
on bro I don't know if that's uh no no I
think he's like trying to bring it back
to like body image issues but it's like
bro what do you mean you're creating
more body images
by by promoting this like unsustainable
level of like having raw mass and
Incredibly low body fat percentage that
you claim you achieve by eating liver
supplements
well it's true it's just it's like what
I don't know it just seems like why is
that relevant to him this right now but
it gets better it gets but that part I
was like I don't know about that one
liver our people are hurting at record
rates with depression autoimmune anxiety
low ambition in life that's weird
our young men are hurting the most
feeling lost weak and submissive so I
made it my job submissive he's reading
off of something I think that's true
yeah I'm looking at his eyes it's
submissive I mean I found out no but
like he's it's his I'm dead yeah
oh yeah he's definitely reading yeah
that's not top Dome
men are too submissive they're funny
my wife pegged me last night and uh oh
clear there wasn't all enough steroids
God
[Laughter]
there's nothing wrong with getting
pegged if that's what you're into no
it's just like but you know what I mean
he says oh my God just saying I'll teach
him preach a simple elegant solution
called ancestral living that he is
reading straight up so people no longer
have yourself so we can collectively
definitely it's 20th highest and most
dominant form this is my fight but that
to me like I don't like that to me if
I'm like if I've seen someone read it's
like how actual genuine is this I'm
making kind of that now it's just like
[ __ ] man
but have you considered all the people
that are sad yeah
you're right there are people who commit
suicide yeah they're out there you know
so steroids
well spreading the message I've been on
several podcasts and when asked if I'd
ever taken steroids I've always said no
I don't touch this stuff you're gonna
touch this stuff never touch the stuff
that was a lie
I've been convinced myself that this had
nothing to do with the ancestral message
I convinced myself really that can I ask
can I ask can this guy put on a shirt
now that the [ __ ]
I feel bad on it genuinely but then I
kind of don't cause I'm like well you
did it and you benefited from it so dude
his titty Valley because his pecs are so
crazy I remember just staring at him and
the there was like a whole valley of
there's like a river of sweat down it's
Teddy Canyon bro damn I was just
smelling him and looking at his pity
River it was crazy bro
who the [ __ ] am I cheating I convinced
myself
okay Brian placeholder for a far more
important conversation I convinced
myself that this would overshadow that
36 years of working out usually twice a
day without
Peds
I've convinced myself
usually in the fitness category driving
to an unproductive conversation
and I had convinced myself that this
would be the wrong message to send to
the 15 year old boys
so I continually dismissed it and I dug
myself into a bigger and deeper hole
I have only myself to blame I did that
and it was all wrong
I will be better I will talk about it
openly because I believe that there's a
time and a place for pharmacological
intervention monitored and managed by a
trainer that is not in the tenants
dude like you can't just insert that
like you can't just assert a
pharmacological intervention and
somewhere in the 910 and stuff hold on
under sun and sleep
the Mormon church can add patch notes
and allow people to drink like soda or
you know allow black people in the
Mormon church or [ __ ] gay marriage or
whatever then you know he can add an
ancestral tender it just doesn't fit bro
you can't go from like sun sleep
pharmaceutical intervention under the
care of trained clinicians it just
doesn't fit but I guess try [ __ ] you
know
oh [ __ ] oh Brian damn
this is tough this is hitting you hard
one of the more wild Parts about his
stack though like when he talks about
his dietary habits and stuff like he
does genuinely follow a rigorous uh
workout and diet for sure Diet also
includes dextrose which I thought was
interesting because he's always like I
never eat sugar unless I treat myself to
it but like he's not he's like taking
dextro supplements afterwards after like
his workouts and stuff too so like that
was there's like weird things that he
just did not mention
or talk about that he does that could be
instructive that could be informative
for people who want to work out and and
get to that level so then so then it
just it just leads you to the idea that
like the focus was then selling
something other than everything else
right and if you read the emails that
like
that's what it's all about right he's
talking about like investing crazy
resources to with the goal of growing
his brand to a million followers by this
date oh [ __ ] I didn't even know any of
that yeah it's all in the emails because
he had like this Manifesto yeah yeah
it's all in there wow yeah well he
reached out to everyone he even reached
out to more plates more dates before he
uh you know came out like he had people
on his team reaching out to more place
more days like he was literally emailing
anyone who would listen who would help
him out and like remove his back fat I
guess which was really good problem and
back fat you have back fat yeah that's
like the worst part really yeah so
that's the thing he's just fat on your
back it's like everyone genetically
can't even see it though when I when I
see him he just looks like he's got like
[ __ ] crazy muscles on I don't know I
mean it's it's obviously a dysmorphia
thing right wait you have back fat
issues Hassan I have fat issues all over
I'm like 20 body fat either more
um
but I mean I'm more exactly the average
person but like right especially right
now I'm nowhere near my uh Prime so I'm
do you drink a lot of sugar
no I I only drink diet soda diet soda
can you guys educate me a little bit
about like body fat like what is the
ideal percentage how do you even know
what's your percentage men and women are
so uniquely different when it comes to
like what's ideal yeah
um
and just is overall hormone stuff yeah
but that's a part of it as well
but but there's no really like ideal I
mean obviously what's healthy yeah like
I mean it just depends on the person
what they really want um I think there's
a certain level that this they consider
obese but I think I'm actually
considered obese by like regular
standards of measurement really just
because it's BMI that's [ __ ] because
of your weight to your height exactly so
you're obese technically yeah so your
body your body Fat's got to be super low
right body fat is pretty low it
fluctuates though like I definitely
fluctuate a lot with my body fat
depending on how consistent I have
dieting and [ __ ] but
um there's no like ideal really how you
feel best like I think if if it's too
high and you I mean honestly the thing
is more important is your body fat as
your blood work like Everyone likes to
think of like this outward which yeah is
important but you can be healthy be a
little bit more overweight as long as
like you're doing all the other things
you need to be doing and you could see
that more by blood work than by like how
fat someone actually is how often do you
do blood work every three months well
yeah nice make sure you're good you're
on the right track yeah always I don't
think well I guess since pregnancies I
did it a lot but like on a normal I
don't ever go do it yeah I just think
it's good to know like you maybe don't
need to do it every three months like
maybe every six months every you know
six months really just to see what's
going on because like things could
change that you could just all like
change a little bit because like even
things as simple as like vitamin D
deficiency and not having enough and not
even knowing that you have that it could
affect so much like your sex drive like
your ability to sleep like so much like
just your your overall like ability to
beat like sicknesses and you can just
change it by just taking more of this
and you wouldn't even know because you
don't know right so getting blood work
done could be so beneficial and just
knowing like because you know if you do
it long enough you'll know when you're
consistent with the supplements what the
effect it's having and then knowing you
start to gauge how you feel based on
like the information you now know from
inside it's different than just how you
feel outside if you could relate how
like what's going on inside to how I
feel outside then you kind of know
eventually at some point without always
getting a checking like oh I'm probably
off on this I'm probably off on that
based on my ability to sleep easy or
stay asleep Etc so there's a lot of
little things you could change that just
have actual drastic effects from art and
you can also find like real like early
uh diseases yeah
check all these things like great and
know what's going on I think it makes
sense at least I have one last question
can I ask one last question yeah uh
Bradley what do you think about uh uh
the like Biometrics devices like you got
the what is it the aura ring I think
it's one of them wait what is that he's
talking about these measurements to like
measure like heart rate and like stuff
like that okay okay all right so I've
tried I've tried the the Amazon has one
I think it's like the whip one the one
that goes on your wrist I've tried the
aura ring yeah this one I have yeah I
think I don't know overall I think
they're cool like as far as tracking
sleep I think it's really interesting
that's something I'm more I've been more
interested in lately because I know how
important it is and uh like tracking
your actual deep sleep versus like just
like trying to be asleep yeah and you
could that does actually gauge that
pretty does it do that based on your
breathing based on your breathing and
your movement because when you're in
deep breath sleep you're like dead oh
yeah not dead but you're just like
you're not moving but like when you're
before that you're kind of like you
might be doing this yeah yeah it engages
all that to know that you haven't hit
that day I would love to know that yeah
I do like that thing I like I've had the
ring and I really did like it I just
wasn't consistent with it after after
time I was like okay I kind of get it
yeah
I have the work the most everything is
like when you drink alcohol and then you
go to [ __ ] sleep
interesting really there you go it
depresses you you're like holy I do need
to say that we are currently at 22 000
votes okay okay I mean now you're doing
this now no I'm not because you're just
encouraging it look 22. I mean you're
bringing us up there for everybody did
Steve jerk off his uh 90 yeah you just
now Focus attention no I'm not guys stop
voting yes it's [ __ ] insane it's like
we're literally sitting here telling you
it didn't happen yeah but now they're
now they're going back to that I'm
telling them I'm saying this is Ethan
the host of the show that you like and
what he didn't do it we know where this
would go or like if you go cow style
yeah oh I love I love you so much
they're so good I still don't really
know what cow style is how style is like
reverse
yeah bro that's [ __ ] Harley sorry I'd
like to get some reverse cow like that's
a reverse cow yeah where'd they get that
one from oh cow style like cowgirl yeah
oh I never heard of called cow style
yeah I thought because because he's
jerking off his dog he's talking about
cow style I thought that was like some
zoology thing do a file thing to reverse
cow all right let's keep watching let's
work our way through this you know he
knows too much that's all I'm gonna say
he knows too much I know I know too much
that man
that man knows a lot yeah he's a
creative yeah so you guys want to finish
this or we get it
I guess we get it yeah just listen to me
the reading off the thing is just making
I don't I just I didn't know that until
I watched it and you got my live
reaction I just feel like that sucks
all right Brian also okay well the thing
we got this bag I think he's gonna get
sued though I think he's gonna he may
lose everything because he did commit
fraud he sold his supplement on false
pretense false advertising that uh he
was not taking steroids he achieved that
body via the obviously the hard work
which he's very upfront about but front
through his supplements and what if
there's like disclaimers on the
supplements that say there's not we have
them here yeah he can get sued damn I
think it's possible that's tough I think
he might get uh I don't know if it'll
happen but uh what he failed to address
so far and maybe he will eventually but
is that like people aren't
upset that he took steroids if people
are upset that he was not honest about
it and it seemed like steroids which
helped him achieve that body steroids in
like a ridiculous work ethic that helped
him achieve that body was actually being
done as a consequence of a ridiculous
work ethic and the ancestral tenants
that's it that's the main point yeah
that makes sense well we we had a lawyer
on and consulted with them on on
Wednesday and he said he he thinks he's
got a big liability and civil laws do
you think there's a liability for the
person who like Derek and the people who
put this stuff out on the internet
wait who's Derek uh
um the channel more place more days he
put this like oh no no no no okay not at
all
if liver King just admit that it was
real you mean like the person who leaked
that yeah yeah yeah isn't there some
sort of it's not MediCal it's not
MediCal documents so it's not between
him and his doctor it's between him and
like literally random like a bodybuilder
you're talking about like yeah he [ __ ]
up yeah he [ __ ] up got it yeah liver
[ __ ] up writing all this it's not like
a confidential email that you don't care
damn also uh apparently uh King liver
thanked uh Derek more place more dates
on his uh Instagram story for like
coming out and like you know give me the
courage wow this is very promo it's very
prominental
okay damn yes so uh 91 now I don't know
why [ __ ] this [ __ ] you guys keep
increasing people in my track keep
saying they're going over there to vote
I'm sorry we got no tell them to vote no
and I'm saying
wow they're just being silly can you
guys can you guys vote no for me yeah
yeah please vote no game when you I
already voted I did vote Yes
but that was before we talked in there
before we talked about
before we talked about it in great
detail
so I've voted yes but but I changed my
mind it's all good all right listen we
we definitely squashed the beef yeah so
we have some activities some uh team
building activities we have to go work
out now Ethan you and I have to go and
work out a zoo culture yeah come to the
new one so I'm open to a new gym in
January I'd love to yeah it's gonna be
an Encino on havenhurst and Ventura
let's do it we'll do it when we go there
maybe not that shoot up there maybe not
just like right away you know like
where do you put steroids in your thigh
and your arm not I'm not asking because
I think you know in the muscle oh just
in the muscle yeah because like you know
people you take steroids and they do
this and it's like that's gnarly well
you don't put it in your face don't put
in your vein oh another question if you
guys watched killer Sally killer Sally
yeah oh yeah I did I haven't watched it
though I saw I saw it I was like I want
to watch this I'm just having a time to
watch it because it's kind of like about
steroids in a way yeah yeah because
there it's a couple they're both
bodybuilders and
thank you so much and uh yeah we'll work
out soon yeah you guys are more than
welcome all right someone said that
people will never be within 10 miles of
that place
yeah that was cool
thanks Hassan
okay so I want to do some some uh
like I said team building exercises so
first thing is I wanted to have a
strength competition with you obviously
we're gonna have to handicap you okay
so I was thinking arm wrestling but okay
all these guys get to have their hand on
my hand
are you good at arm wrestling do you do
that great yeah no it's a lot of
technique right yeah it's all technique
oh really yeah I don't think it's like
it's not always the biggest guy or the
strongest guy it's like knowing how to
use it yeah yeah yeah sure
I've got I watched that [ __ ] on Tick
Tock those guys are same there's like
this one World Champ I don't know his
name but he's like undefeated some guys
are yeah I mean some of these are huge
and his his arm looks so [ __ ] crazy
his hand is huge right it's got to be
yeah there's a one guy with the free can
yeah he has like a his can the canister
looks like a tiny baby soda yeah like
what causes that is that like a oh I
think you showed me that I don't know if
the birth defect or birth enhancement
[ __ ] yeah for a [ __ ] arm wrestling
for sure um where are we doing the arm
wrestling guys
are you guys coming here
yeah bring your I hope you Juiced this
morning
are you gonna need all the help we can
get all right so here we go the Feats of
Strength me versus Bradley
no just me versus Bradley and maybe some
help
so
so if you could if you could so how you
guys gonna help me out here
just let us know if you need help yeah I
mean call us and tag Us in I would need
help
okay so you guys can't get in here maybe
five okay
I feel like we're still gonna lose
all right you guys I'm gonna need I'm
coming maybe on that side here let me
thank you more room maybe do Bradley
look at him
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
okay wait we're not going yet we're not
going yet
dude Bradley's gonna [ __ ] kill us all
right all right all right get in here
Dad all right there we go wait can you
guys see it yeah yeah okay ready go
wait my elbow's not on the ground
I couldn't hold it dude that was good I
thought we were gonna lose [ __ ] because
the elbow came up this is the elbow came
up yeah my elbow came up yeah listen
listen I thought you were strong man
Transformers just beat me beat your arms
all right
the Power Rangers yeah they started
coming out more and more Ela joined the
fridge transformed I think she threw it
over the edge yeah yeah I felt good at
the two and then now well yeah we needed
help listen I'm strong enough that was
good all right so then we have another
competition we were doing a tug of war
me versus you oh I'm gonna win that and
and then everybody let's go yeah
we're gonna go back to that we have a
camera in back we'll be there in a sec
yeah yeah
where's the uh
so here we have green over here okay so
Bradley's actually feeling confident on
this one yeah 100 are you experienced uh
uh uh
pulling stuff yeah I'm gonna pull stuff
okay all right so
how's the audio there is it picking up
okay how much you weigh
like 220. how much do you weigh oh my
God bro ah okay pretty heavy for you
how much UA Bradley 260. isn't that
funny when I was at my fastest I was at
250. you only had 10 pounds on me he
only had 10 pounds on me bro damn I
yeah you were dead you were big yeah I
was [ __ ] all right so so yeah I know so
who's on our team because he's got if
he's holding the camera that's not
enough manpower
Lena come on
ladies and then we have here's our line
so let me get close here we've got to be
behind this so give me a little rope
give me a little slack here Bradley
all right so you feel good on that yeah
okay
give me as much slack as you can as
you're comfortable with
okay good good good so so Bradley you're
good there uh we got me a b Lina yeah
Zach dude we're gonna
all right and then um
all right so so you guys know the rules
we got the lines here
we got the black line there which is the
center
all right you're ready for this one
[ __ ] dude he's all wrapped up man watch
your hands
dude this is like final boss [ __ ]
we're not pulling yet I'm just testing
this is the [ __ ] tug of war final
boss right all right everyone ready
all right here we go go oh it's good
games
[Applause]
[Music]
dude you held your own nothing to be
ashamed about but I did win
the boy right there probably 250s yeah
we had like a thousand pounds
so honestly if I had more grips
[ __ ] dude all right let's go back good
job everybody I'm gonna pee real quick
yeah don't
yeah don't feel too bad Bradley uh
yeah I mean I I listen I thought he was
strong I'm coming out here I'm wanting
all the strength competitions not a big
deal we'll see
um you're so strong Ethan we have
another one
yeah
we need one
here I am actually
thank you Cameron this is me after today
looking good
no that's all natural so yeah that's
that's all Natty baby
um we got the tug of war we got the arm
wrestling
the typing ones just not even fair at
this point
maybe he can have his his boys back them
up where they all type
are you guys fast typers oh he feels
confident you guys both feel confident
[Laughter]
are you fast typer Bradley
oh
because I thought I said okay well let's
do the strength ones and then let's
bring it to my wife I play video games
when you played everything I grew up
playing World of Warcraft Diablo story
that's all my [ __ ] all that what do you
play right now I've been playing God of
War I just beat it yeah I just I got to
play I think I'm like towards the end I
just Beat It by the way Dan yeah it's
fun so fun
um it's very like a it's just a pretty
game like it feels like you're playing a
movie yeah it looks beautiful I love the
way they weave the story Into the game
and uh but I'm fast at typing okay [ __ ]
let's go but we're gonna do a
composition there can we do our eyes
closed eyes closed typing okay I can do
that okay let's go let's do let's do uh
I mean I'm not I don't look down in my
hand you got to look at the screen
because it's like a typing game okay
yeah
but I can close my eyes and type
all right so so we're gonna take turns
here okay
this isn't my ideal keyboard yeah like
what is this [ __ ]
that's rough this is some [ __ ]
I got it wait so what are we typing yeah
so you're gonna we're gonna pull up like
Math Blasters or some [ __ ] oh I gotta do
math I thought I was just typing oh my
God
are you pulling something up Ian
oh
number one thank you thank you yeah so
okay there's a typing test
website here okay okay okay
all right here we go this is exciting
yeah this is good
all right let me just sit let me just
see if it's working yeah it is I'm gonna
refresh it I just seeing if it works
oh this is cool it's just random okay
hold on I'm taking this off I'm gonna
take that nice
yeah let's go
okay
oh God this is not an ideal
I'm gonna put it there you guys make me
do that
I guess because you're looking at that
screen oh [ __ ] you're right right [ __ ]
here I'll do it like this okay okay
I've never used this keyboard before
yeah I'm a little nervous I'm a little
nervous I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
nervous about the keyboard too
it's hard okay all right you know what
oh here we go
pretty good all the periods are gonna
[ __ ] me up
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what happened oh it
stops you when you get a typo
damn
wow yeah it appearance is gonna mess me
up the period's tough because I know you
know don't need type periods when you
play video games right
you just kind of like damn [ __ ]
[Music]
30 seconds left on the clock oh wow
Dan you're doing good I'm now I'm
nervous I wish I went first
I couldn't do this
damn
[ __ ]
10 seconds
you're pretty good at this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's for a minute 90 8 that was hard
because the spelling if you hit the type
well you just read it
okay you don't have to that's true
sometimes I mix up the eyes and knees
and stuff but that what threw me off is
it stops if you get it wrong so just be
prepared to back it up okay let's see
is that better than you thought could
you I I I was telling these guys I can
do a hundred nobody believed me I mean I
get around your mic oh sorry I didn't
help you out at all did I make him
Bradley run his own show here
all right
get nice and comfortable in there
there's keyboard I know it's not it's a
bad situation I know it's hard it's hard
just getting into it
okay so click um
oh wait I gotta do it I'll just refresh
I think
okay go ahead whenever you're ready
oh I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] you want to
start over yeah yeah you can start over
here it feels so shitty you can start
over Okay do you have to capitalize it
yeah oh I'm done bro I'm [ __ ] done I
know it sucks the cap sucks hold on
let's find one can we do unformal can we
do like video game version yeah yeah no
dude the capitalization okay this one
doesn't have a lot of cops it just says
that one r at the top okay I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my God it's the keyboard if
you're not used
yeah you have to go back it's super
messed up
no dude
should have played more I'm sorry bro I
did like typing classes and stuff you
know what I mean keyboard bro and it's a
bag honestly I feel like I should break
this keyboard you can it's [ __ ] you want
to break it
I want to see him right here
let's do that yeah let's do that wait
yeah wait wait
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh my God this game
is stupid bro
dumb game that is a dumb game actually
you know what that is a dumb game you're
right [ __ ] that game oh that's just
[ __ ] oh my God [ __ ] dude I saw that
thing hello that's the keyboard that
felt good
I felt really good I felt good for me
yeah that was fun I gotta give you my
you crossed that we're throwing a line
now because that was ten times more
difficult than I thought it was going to
be oh [ __ ] I'm bleeding oh no it's okay
can we get first aid stuff yeah I'm fine
yeah we have first aid stuff how'd that
happen you did on your knees yeah my
hand just I don't know too much passion
yeah a little too much
it was worth it that was awesome yeah
all good yeah we got some bad you need a
Band-Aid or something no we'll see
yeah just uh just whatever stuff that
makes it burn hydrogen peroxide or like
whatever cleaning stuff yeah we got we
got all that I don't need that yeah
so
[Applause]
um as the last thing I want to do and
first of all I've had such a great time
with you sorry no I'm good yeah okay
I appreciate it it was fun it was fun
but there's one more thing I want to do
and there's no pressure for you to do
this okay but like Ayahuasca this could
be a bonding experience for us
okay have you ever had the spicy chip oh
you're [ __ ] crazy I saw that earlier
I'm not gonna lie I saw that earlier and
I was like I do not want to do that you
don't have to God damn it to people
before and they all they've all said no
oh you know you're so bad
so you don't have to eat the whole thing
like we'll go have seas and and it's
like it's a bonding experience but again
no pressure it'll [ __ ] your day it could
are you good with spicy food yeah but
not like this is like [ __ ] your whole
day up yeah no I did it I ate a whole
chip you're kind of down for like 10
minutes but then you're you're gonna be
fine if you're good with spicy yeah it's
not that bad [ __ ] yeah let's split one
are you sure I don't want to appear I
don't pressure you do what kind of
things do you have like like milk and
stuff we got we have milk and stuff and
popsicles and ice cream and I think so
we'll confirm oh this is horrible no I
know and I sorry you don't have to I saw
this earlier yeah no well on Monday
we're having a competition well then
what you want to do it now and I have to
offer the guests damn it's a bonding
experience Ila also it helps me lose
weight because I just [ __ ] for two days
no I'm just kidding just kidding a lot
of valid weight loss thing I'm just
kidding don't do that don't eat this is
the spicy foods
we're seeing if we have a God or the
accompaniments because now I'm thinking
like if you guys do it I have to do it
yeah
so it's easier
yeah if you do it I'll do it but if you
do it I'm doing it all right we're going
30 yeah we're going third season oh my
God you're uh supposed to be doing it
next week
I don't know if Ethan debriefed you on
he doesn't no without me he's worried
that let me see how much but we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out okay
yeah
yeah it's a whole thing
all right bring that out let's get some
cups okay so let's break it into third
I'm scared of this thing me too what are
you scared of I saw them do it and it
looks like it's like so much in your
mouth and like the texture I think I'm
gonna hate it but the thirds I think is
going to be a lot easier yeah because
once the whole chip it's a lot to chew
yeah it just lingers in your mouth I'm
actually proud of you ELO for doing this
what's the hottest food you've eaten
Bradley probably one of these stupid
[ __ ] things you've done this before
not this one I've done the older one
okay so you know what you're getting
yourself in kind of I just but I never
really enjoyed it you know it was like
one of those things I'm like I probably
shouldn't have done that yeah but I'll
do it [ __ ] it you're a good man Bradley
don't get in your cut oh look at that
[ __ ] yeah make sure if you uh touch the
chip don't touch your face no matter
what yeah and as Cameron says after
touching the chat hold it with a t-shirt
it's ridiculous oh yeah okay so we're
we're doing it we're doing it you're
good man Bradley you're the first guest
to accept this yeah that makes sense so
coconut water yeah I need gloves okay do
we have regular water
all right oh [ __ ] so I'm gonna try to
break into thirds I'll take the bigger
piece
oh that was a good break actually
I'm not doing it again next week though
just so you guys know
okay so so you want the smaller one Ela
yes please yes and then you can pick
which which one you want they're pretty
fairly fairly
uh sized damn we're doing Ayahuasca
right now dude that's kind of what this
is I'm just as surprised as you are by
the way you did not tell me about this
[ __ ] all right it's my new thing I asked
when
I did it the last few times yes I did
you did
the champ I thought so
oh popsicles nice oh God can you eat
sugar yeah yeah
this guy's good he's on it sugar
subprime a lot all right so so you
decided or we'll just take it yeah I'll
take that one
thanks bro I had such a fun time I'm so
glad we did this you know you're you're
such a good guy and uh I really by the
way and sorry to tell you this uh this
is not I have nothing to do with this 28
000 votes
20 28 656 to be specific uh ninety
percent [ __ ]
but that's ridiculous it's a CR I mean
it's not true it's not true yeah it's
like they don't know they don't know
they weren't there yeah
my heartbeat is already racing yeah yeah
I feel you I feel you I don't like this
this is nice I this is a special bonding
moment I think we're gonna have together
so I'm excited
and it all fits in your mouth
your guy's a big deal with
deal with drink or eat anything after oh
no no I'm not you can do it well what we
did the whole challenge is to see how
long you can go but we're not even
eating a whole chip so we're leaving
it's not a real challenge we're just
bonding yeah cheers cheers guys thank
you for a great job thank you [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding oh wow
here we go
oh that hit you
you want to clean your finger
okay
that hit you fast yeah you got it down
that fast yeah I tried I thought it was
like better tastes really bad huh yeah
it's terrible the flavor is horrible
yeah probably that's not nope it's not
good at all
I think there's nothing good about it
yeah I'm hot
you guys got that down way faster
yeah let me have
because
I'm trying like not to do it but like
let me know if you guys need anything
all right guys
it does get worse it gets worse yeah
yeah it just keeps getting worse it'll
get a lot worse yeah it probably Peaks
around 10 minutes 10 minutes to get
worse that's where it Peaks oh wow
what that sounds bad
have you seen the prolapse
what what
why'd you just scoop yourself
prolapse I'll take some of that I don't
want to do this
hit me please yeah prolapse yeah
what's what's prolapse
how we Mendoza
you've seen the video
I don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
wow
in my mouth
I need ice
it's not good there's [ __ ] stuck in my
teeth and that's stressing me
[Music]
oh it just keeps getting worse dude
it's not going to leave my mouth it
hurts so bad
my ears
hurry
what are you gonna do with that
it helps
really
this is bad
it hurts my ears
my ears are burning
it just feels like there like there's
fire in my room yeah okay it just keeps
happening like I feel like it just keeps
going
mm-hmm
[Music]
why does it go today it looks like
you're gonna drink it and then you think
it's gonna go down and it just doesn't
oh my God my throat hurts so bad
fire
I gotta just keep this in my walk holy
[ __ ]
don't
what is that oh [ __ ] okay
oh
holy [ __ ] I think it's getting worse
more than last time what are we watching
this is a tick tock that Howie Mandel
posted with no context okay it's not on
the screen obviously when my friend Neil
bent over this happened does somebody
know is this covid relay wait what the
[ __ ] if it is
oh wait whoa
[Applause]
oh God
I don't know what's worse
ah
it is in my ears what's happening that
one's so [ __ ] funny people
I can't talk it's so this is worse the
last time take it off screen that's
gonna maybe just throw up I don't want
to throw up
this happened does somebody know is this
covered related and if it is absolutely
do about it
okay
it feels like it goes away then it
doesn't it comes back in my throat where
does it hurt on the side
look at her throats and her ears hurt
okay yeah so how we posted that why did
he do that
I just showed up on people's is it still
up no he took it down but I was up for
like 17 hours so he said that he didn't
know what it was
and he came on our podcast to explain
you okay do you believe it so bad
that was worse than last time
what are we talking about
[ __ ]
the prolapse the prolapse how he posted
a tick tock was up for 17 hours why did
he do that
I don't know never explain why he did it
yeah he came on the show and he said he
said he didn't know it was a prolapse do
you believe that I thought somebody just
had something on
he said he had they had like I don't
believe it at all
give me up
he lost a bunch of sponsors apparently
really [ __ ] he's lost like a huge deal
for that but it's up 17 hours a bunch of
kids up and now if you go to Howie's
comment section
every comment is just we'll never forget
oh that's [ __ ] that's pretty funny
it's funny that's really funny yeah but
it goes when my friend Neil bent over
this happened
would anyone know if there's covet
related
what do we do about it and if it is what
do we do about it
all right I think I'm good
holy [ __ ] are you okay love yeah it's
starting to feel better yeah that was
really really bad I took out a lot of
stuff on it
I think it was like a
oh my God
good work team
good job guys
the Primal [ __ ] liver king would never
or should I say Brian
Johnson [ __ ]
wow my stomach hurts now it's literally
like just fire in your mouth like right
right here just hurt so [ __ ] bad yeah
I'm proud of you thank you yeah you
crushed that that's not good I cut it
off I don't know why a third was hotter
than the whole thing last time I don't
know maybe it was like maybe this trip
extra [ __ ] on there that was a lot that
was bad
yes okay
um
Lena
yeah she went seven minutes and dad went
10 minutes without anything
really yeah yeah 10 [ __ ] minutes
that's insane yeah
how did you look what yeah blew me away
I only made me win anything
yeah I didn't did I Ethan should have
won something
actually won something for that I went
like three and a half minutes when I did
it 10 minutes is
what were you thinking about
to get through it yeah I I actually did
I I sort of used some meditation
techniques to just kind of disassociate
what were you thinking about I was just
I went to my happy place I was I was in
like a zen garden everything about
Ayahuasca yeah I haven't done Ayahuasca
but I imagine it was a similar kind of
experience damn that's the guy to do
Ayahuasca right yeah yeah Dan's a
natural Shaman he should do it done I'd
love to if you could do that 10 minutes
yeah Ayahuasca no problem we also ran on
to doing the show
what's that it kept on doing the show
right afterwards oh really well okay bro
Ayahuasca I think it's calling your name
let's go put us in touch I will let's
get let's get down on that Journey can
we film it Jen
um maybe I'll pay for it yeah I was
afraid of that I was afraid because I
was thinking about that but I was like I
just want to do it it's a [ __ ] it when
you know there's someone observing you
like that it changes the nature of it
yeah yeah
that sounds like that's a recipe for a
bag is still burning I mean I'm in
you're not broken now I mean it's still
[ __ ] but it's like you know it's half
of what it was yeah yeah it's hot for
sure well badly yes
it's been a great show Absolutely fun
time thank you really appreciate you
coming here appreciate it shout out to
everyone someone show love
that was fun for real I love the setup I
love what you guys are doing it's
honestly really you tell your boys back
at the zoo that I'm an animal I will I
will I'm going to tell them that you're
a beast of a human yeah when I hit that
treadmill every day for an hour that's a
start I'm a real Primo including weekend
even on the weekend no matter what yeah
no matter what
that's a good start thank you yeah 30
pounds come by the gym for real though
I think we would that'd be fun oh yeah
we said now at some point we gotta do
you got to come do my podcast anytime
you tell me I'll be there cool yeah
yeah people are saying um Wadley in the
chat was that the W yeah nice let's go I
love this to close off the pole 31 000
votes yeah that's a whole we know that
that's just gonna be 100 yet I'm gonna
call it I'm gonna call the poll I don't
think I don't think this is swinging but
that we know it didn't happen no I
didn't yeah can we like yeah I guess no
re-ended the poll okay cool solid yeah
but if Steve is down we'll do a show
together yeah that'd be on dealers or
here whatever you guys want I'm down
that'd be awesome cool thank you for
having me come for real thanks bro thank
you guys so much
thank you thank you
yes sir give me that I don't care
whether or not
it was amazing do I just walk off is it
like well we're gonna end it oh yeah so
guys thank you so much that was a that
was a I knew it would be fun but like
this this turned out to be a really
awesome episode so yeah very happy yeah
I enjoyed it Friday
have a good weekend everybody we're back
on Monday as usual do we have anything
fun next week plan
uh yes uh we have a guest next week let
me remind myself oh uh Britney Broski is
coming on
yeah fun yeah we'll see you then what
day is that that on Friday next Friday
okay so guys have a great weekend we'll
see you on Monday thanks for joining us
y'all stay safe stay blessed get in the
gym and stay be an animal yes yes stay
in the gym be a [ __ ] animal
appreciate it man that was dope bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]